This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
[inaudible]
Tom,
Tom and his wife is Dina made a Hashtag.
Why is so fat saying that I'm fat it not accurate.
I got the joke.
You just haven't gotten wet and it's been like three weeks all I get her.
Bobby's on social.
That's a nice shirt.
Was so tight like it might
die if
this fire,
this guy does change.
Okay.
You're going to try to find a way to say that time we know better.
You Bet.
The thing is that nobody,
nobody.
Oh Man.
It's one of my favorite heroes.
So beautiful.
The Sun that is a MC tight jeans back in the day.
That was during the,
when we really kicked off the who is fat Verdis fat while you sleep that night
of our era.
The bird is fat.
The time is fan here and was so excited to have him back today.
It's going to be so much fun,
but we watched a special on Netflix secret time.
Guess what?
He's still fat.
Yeah.
Oh,
uh,
and for those of you wondering,
like,
how did you vote?
He doesn't know.
I've seen it yet either because I got a screener.
How did I get a screener?
I'm a Hollywood movie star.
I'm a television star.
I'm a podcast.
I'm an international comedian,
right?
A director
I say are dancers before the reg is the public state it.
And people were like,
let me give it to you.
So that's how I saw it.
You know,
it's interesting that show,
um,
uh,
insatiable on Netflix right now,
getting a lot of heat for being fat shaming.
Oh,
great.
And then,
and there are like,
uh,
people,
um,
wanting it to be taken down.
It's so silly.
I mean,
I,
I've started watching it.
I'm four episodes and I love it.
Art and Mirin Janette and she's fantastic,
but you know,
uh,
but,
but it's not all bad.
We fat shame Bart.
And for a while we got him to slim down and I got fat.
Shame too.
Don't forget that part.
And it was very useful when she say it worked to your benefit.
100%.
Yeah.
And by the way,
it hasn't really slowed down as much as you think it would.
People comment to me pretty consistently.
Yeah.
Well how do you feel about fat shaming?
I mean,
here's,
here's the truth.
I kind of feel like it's not good for you to be fat.
So people are like,
hey,
we should encourage people to stay fat.
Is that the thinking here?
I'm totally on board with fat shaming.
I a full endorser,
first of all,
I've experienced it,
um,
you know that right now.
And I shamed myself over it.
I knew I shamed myself constantly.
I don't believe in loving myself at my fattest.
I don't believe in accepting myself and I don't want to accept you at your
fantasy,
you know?
So,
um,
yeah,
I mean,
I,
I know there's people who are like,
it's horrible debt.
I think it's world bull to be as fat as you are.
I think so too.
It's unhealthy stopping.
So fat stop being so fat,
it doesn't roast leg
and um,
yeah,
you're going to die sooner.
And here's the thing,
overeating is an addiction of sorts.
Correct.
Would you agree?
Unless it is truly glandular or truly a medical percentage of people are like my
thyroid accent.
So there's,
there's a handful of people who it's a medical thing.
Sure,
sure.
Yeah.
But then for the rest of us who have weight,
you're just overeating.
It's an addiction.
Um,
so why,
you know what I'm saying?
You know,
you're not supposed to be that fat.
You're not as fast.
But I'm saying that.
So why don't we get into addiction shaming yet there are TV shows.
Where are we?
We glorify shaming intervention for instance.
Isn't that then,
shouldn't we say,
oh we can't drug addict shame isn't that it is a shame.
And they tried to embarrass them basically.
That's right.
So there are entire and hoarders,
that's a show based on it.
That's an addiction.
And if they're super happy and you're very fat,
you're in denial.
Yeah.
You're not happy.
You're not,
you know,
that's not,
shouldn't be that fat.
No,
it's true.
It is true.
True.
Nor should you a drink a lot more than you do drugs or try anything in excess.
Excess isn't good.
All the addiction is bad.
Dude,
I'm trying to take,
I mean like I'm fat now.
I'm not fat.
Well I'm,
I'm saying I'm actively still trying to lose weight.
I'm losing baby working out,
eating better,
eating right at my absolute fattest.
If you had asked me like,
um,
are you okay with your weight?
Maybe,
I don't know if publicly I would have been like,
yeah,
fine if I,
if I would have had it that lie going to myself,
I know that privately I definitely wouldn't have.
And you know,
it's tough to accept the fat shaming at first,
but then you're like,
you know what?
I need to hear this.
I'm serious.
It's true.
And we,
you know,
we talk about Latin culture,
how they're very over,
like they call you Flocka if you're skinny or Gordo,
if you're a fatty and Hungarian culture at same thing,
they will tell you to your face that you're fat.
When I would used to go to Peru like much more often,
like you literally walk off the plane and you're talking,
you're seeing a relative you haven't seen in maybe two or three years and you'd
give them a hug.
And it's this big celebratory,
you know,
it's an affectionate culture.
Sure.
You give him a big hug,
kiss,
oh my God.
And they're like,
it's just,
you can go to him and we would tell you right away he looked pretty fat.
Sure.
Like God dammit dude.
And you're like,
I just got here.
Like you're ruining my whole fucking trip there.
Like that right away.
I don't know what the stupid American thing is that we should love ourselves
when we're unhealthy.
We're overweight.
It's not good.
There's nothing good about being overweight.
No,
there's not.
It is an addiction like any other addiction,
like alcohol,
like smoking years.
Why are we,
and we have no problem shaming smokers.
How come there's no campaign?
Oh,
here you shame me.
Your cigarette shaming or your alcohol shaming.
And sometimes there is,
there's that pushback.
If you know someone in person,
they'll be like,
don't give me any shit about smoking.
And sometimes I'm like,
all right,
I'm going to,
I'm not going to give you shit about,
go ahead and smoke.
But as a general rule,
the public is allowed to smoke shame.
You're allowed to go.
That addiction we at were okay with because it's inherently bad,
but then again,
so is being overweight.
That's inherently of course the problem is there's so many people that are
overweight and there's such an overeating bad food like culture that we live in
here that people just go like,
let's not all feel badly all the time.
That we should feel bad though.
But that's how you change is you feel bad and you say,
I don't like how this looks.
I don't like how this feels.
I don't want to live.
All right.
Um,
and this is why we're doing bird a service.
I'm saying we're hooking them up.
I'm in brass balls beach.
It's all sold out this weekend.
Thank you everybody for getting those tickets.
You know what I'm,
you feel me?
I'm talking about,
I'm trying to see what's coming up after that.
Uh,
Sharp Lake titties,
that's all sold out.
There are what?
60 tickets left to the late show in Eugene.
EU,
gene,
gene genes,
boys seed,
Idaho's all sold out
tickets at the second show added in spall Sacramento.
Fresno Fart.
No,
California.
Bakersfield.
Those are an October Bart Myers,
Jack me off bill and the second show in Orlando,
the second show only has one,
two,
300 tickets left.
That's November 3rd.
Um,
Augusta,
Georgia who also in November,
the second show in
Montclair,
which is Wednesday,
November 14th,
that has some tickets and with the third show and fill her up delphia that is
November 7th
teeth at the Merriam theater.
You can get tickets to that Tom [inaudible] dot com slash tour I gave people a
heads up.
I'll remind you again the uh,
if you go to my website and you go to the tour page and you see that prompt that
pops up and you put in your email address,
you will receive notification of something before the rest of the public does.
Oh Wow.
That's neat.
I want to do that.
Um,
you know,
I can only tell you that much right now,
but go there,
throw your email in and you will get a message that you might like about some
stuff I have coming up.
That's all I can tell you right now.
It's exciting.
Yeah.
Jean Jean,
Jean Jean.
Oh guys.
So thanksgiving weekend.
It's that Saturday when you guys were all sick of your family and you want to
get it
the f out of the house.
Come see me at the house of Blues and Man Diego,
California.
Yeah.
Tickets are moving really fast.
There's only a few left on that one.
And then um,
December
or seventh in,
fill her up.
Delphia I will be there.
And then,
um,
the 8th of December do dark titties.
8:00 PM show is sold out.
I've added eight late show,
10 30 show tickets at Christina P on line.
Check it out.
Try it out.
Come in for strokes.
Uh,
Ali Zinzer wrote this.
This is called double pipe.
Oh alleys.
I remember members.
Yeah,
he's always got some good stuff.
Cause are all right Jean,
this is a huge episode.
We're going to have our great friend burnt Chrif color all.
Yeah,
we burnt Crysler aren't Crisler is going to be here.
There's so much to go over.
Big News too.
We've got big news to share.
Big News to share all kinds of things to talk about.
Get into it.
Jean Jean,
here we go.
Times.
If the cow refuses,
they'll stimulate its sexual organs.
This unusual technique,
the Cadillac tax,
it's natural response to a calf attempting to suckle.
Don't bring anyone loving to live.
No bombing the fungus.
Well,
welcome.
Welcome to your mom's house.
Tastes like shit.
What are you drinking?
Kava ice shit.
Ah.
You know what I'm saying?
That was horrifying.
Yeah.
That's what they do in some cultures,
I guess.
Yeah,
I know.
Yeah.
Well,
no,
he was he licking,
he was stimulating what?
I think he was looking at her badge or blowing air to it or something to
stimulate the lactation.
Yeah,
but a calf,
a calf doesn't lick the mother's vagina.
Tick get milk.
I mean,
this seems like it says simulates the sexual organ and that's what does it,
so,
oh wow.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
Oh,
check it out again.
Please don't
times.
If the cow refuses,
they'll stimulate its sexual organ.
It is
this unusual technique encourages the Cadillac tax.
It's natural response to a calf attempting to satellite.
Okay.
Hold on.
Young boys are often responsible for carrying out this task.
Nice.
Yeah.
What else?
Another Dinka custom is showering under urinating couch.
Oh,
that's nice.
Well,
he's doing,
he's got a euro turns.
Their hair are popular.
Look for both children and adults.
Probably kids always getting this stuff done to that.
A lot of piss too.
I mean that was such an enormous,
like it's such a huge amount of as a shower.
Yeah.
I mean that didn't goes,
Huh?
That's a real pissed.
That's a golden shower.
Yeah.
I hate when you go like piss on me and someone just has like a little stream.
Sure.
A piss,
you know.
I mean,
look that I try it.
And African cow customer.
You're showering under urinating counter.
Sure.
I mean that's like somebody,
a hose.
Matt is a night at Nice custom.
What would you rather do?
Two jobs to choose from?
Okay.
You're a member of the Dinka tribe.
You're,
you're over there.
Do you a take the cow ps pissed shower all day.
It's nine to five.
It's what you're doing.
Account p's on your head.
Sure.
Or once an hour you stimulate the cows vagina with your mouth.
The way I would stimulate the vagina with your mouth.
Yeah,
I think I'm not into as much the getting urinated on by the cow and like buckets
of it.
Okay.
What if I change the parameter then again,
I get that cool hair color change,
right?
That's the whole point.
Yeah.
I mean,
you could use nitrogen peroxide,
Odell Beckham Jr.
Look,
I don't even know who that is.
I know,
but you,
you could use peroxide hydrogen,
but that,
that's too easy.
You got to get the cow urinating.
What if it's just once an hour or a cow passes on you or you stimulate the
Oregon organs?
MMM,
just once an hour or the,
the cab pisses on me.
How often?
No.
Once an hour it's like Dang,
timer goes off and you either get pissed on by the cow or Yg,
stimulate their mouth,
stimulating with your mouth on a cow's Vasheen what he was doing.
Dude,
you're crazy.
I would choose getting pissed on any day.
Why?
Because I don't put my mouth on a cow's filthy vagina.
First of all,
how do you know I'm not turned on by that?
No,
that would be a first.
Yeah,
you're into that.
baby.
It's an animal's badge.
It's not that big of a deal.
Okay.
I think I would do it and had no problem with it.
I'd rather get peed on.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean,
you realize that you're covered in lights for me.
I'm like,
Eh,
I,
and then I'm back to doing what I do.
If you're just drenched in Calabasas,
my head,
if you see how it does dripping off his face,
it was okay,
but then I can put my head under water and then I can,
what do you think you smell like after that?
It's not lavender bodywash.
Yeah,
but in the Dinka tribe,
maybe they like the way that smells.
Oh,
now you're moving to the whole tribe.
You're,
you're,
you're a member of the tribe,
dude.
That's number one.
You're moving to wherever these people live.
You're sleeping in their huts or wherever they live.
You're doing the dances and you're,
you're licking the,
the,
the cow badge.
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't think so.
I think it's fine.
I think I'm fine.
I'll tell you what I'm just distracted by right now.
Hmm.
How beautiful I am.
Yes.
Number am yes.
Number two,
my Starbucks service is going down downhill.
Oh my God.
My local,
my a one Starbucks.
I've noticed some turnover.
I notice some of
higher performers are gone now.
This is the thing is that I've noticed that you've been,
you've,
you're a connoisseur of the Starbucks in our neighborhood.
You,
you tried them all and this is your favorite place.
That's location.
And this is because they know your order.
When you come in they say hello to you.
They have great customer service.
They're on top of it.
They're just,
yeah,
it's just,
I mean you go out of your way to go there because the other ones or drive
through this one.
We have to park that one.
Nah,
I mean the drive through one is chaos.
It's that is,
is that an exit for the 101 terrible.
Yeah,
it's chaos.
It's at a gas station too and there's a line of cars,
the clutter up the gas station and the boulevard.
It's a really bad place for a Starbucks now.
But I'm saying that you go the extra mile and you park your car.
Yeah.
And often you make LJ and I wait in the truck while you go in and you get your
comp,
your,
your diarrhea in a cup.
And then,
uh,
but you're telling me today your experience was different.
So what happened?
Well,
I've noticed it like there was a couple like really great employees there.
Yeah,
I mean these,
these
people,
seriously,
I'll walk in and go,
hi Tom.
Hi.
No like extra ice.
It's ready to go.
I'm like,
what the fuck man.
Like that.
They know you,
they anticipate your needs and I see them do it to other people.
It's not just me movie star,
TV star,
it's other regular common petty people.
Peasants also got good attention from.
Sure.
So I would be like,
wow.
Even like a regular,
you know,
bottom dwellers,
getting nice attention from them.
It not just,
Oh you know,
this celebrity guy comes in.
So I was like,
this is the Starbucks.
And I noticed probably three or four faces that I would see on routine that I'm
like,
these are all stars.
This is the best location that group into.
And I don't know if they either moved on in careers.
What I did here,
I overheard a little gossip was somebody asking about one of them and they're
like,
oh,
they moved so and so to this location to like get that thing up and running.
So what they did is they outsource their good employees to teach,
teach or Starbucks how to be better.
Right.
And now we have shitty,
you're Starbucks,
you're suffering such bullets.
So dumb.
It's like what they did in the late eighties and nineties here in la La Unified
School district.
They would take the gang bangers from the bad neighborhoods and then bust them
into the nice ones and were like,
I think that's a nationwide thing babe.
It's like giving people an opportunity to go to better school.
It was a bad idea.
Here's the thing,
if it's not la,
you know I don't care about no,
it was a,
it was a horrible idea.
No,
and then they took the good kids and put them in the gang banger schools.
They put kids in gang bangers.
Why would it happen to Brody Stevens?
Why would they do that?
Because it was,
it was an exchange program.
Right.
They take the kids from the rougher neighborhoods,
put them in the nicer ones and vice versa and ended up being a huge disaster.
Okay.
So this is what I'm saying to Starbucks is a corporation.
Bad idea.
And it's a big thumbs down from me.
Yeah.
Very disciplined.
Happened today that you felt that you are not served well,
I mean there's just little things you notice.
First of all I know is on that APP yesterday.
Then when we stopped at that same place you wanted water and so I try to get you
a water on the APP and it said sold out.
I was like,
oh,
they're sold out of water.
That's crazy.
I went in there and I saw like 200 bottles of water.
So I told the Lady,
I go says sold out in your APP,
but you know,
just so you know,
she's like,
oh,
what happened was we probably were sold at at some point and somebody just
forgot to turn it back on.
I go,
okay.
Then I came today,
says sold out again still.
Yeah.
And the same girls there.
I didn't bring it up and I'm like,
oh,
they're just like missing a beat,
you know.
And that was yesterday.
So they had all full 24 hours to rectify the situation.
And I know that some of you losers out there listening are like give them a
break,
but that's why you're a fucking loser.
Right.
Because you have low standards.
Sure.
You know,
I have higher standards cause
I'm a fucking winner.
Right.
I agree.
Yeah.
You've got a winner's attitude.
I love Starbucks is,
you know,
yeah.
I was a Barista in the summer of 1997 at the do whatever your job is to try to
do it well,
Tarzana location.
Sure.
Yeah.
I'm a trained Barista and I believe I love star.
Oh I saw you here this morning at the house.
Go Flip,
flip flip and you just yeah.
Whack in the form of filter.
I steam the milk.
She's impressive
stuff.
I did the call,
right?
Yeah.
That will tall nonfat latte Latte,
double tall.
Um,
but anyways,
I'm just,
I'm just like,
you know why I don't like to see you upset.
And you came back in the car and you were very upset about your level of
service.
They were really,
they're just dragon.
They're just dragging in there now.
And then there's be,
you know,
there's three people waiting.
It still takes you like 10,
15 minutes.
Like,
I'm getting an iced coffee.
Come on man.
Your shit together.
Yeah.
Source,
whatever.
Well,
I'll tell you why I'm disappointed and I,
I agree with you a Starbucks because they really do put a lot of priority into
training their people to be good.
I know.
And to be efficient and to be familiar with the products and to know everything.
So I,
I'm,
I'm a little upset for you because I believe in Starbucks as a company and I
know that this is my version of top dog.
It is.
And I,
I didn't want to point that out and be a complete wifey to you.
This is basically the behavior.
Yeah,
I understand.
Yeah.
So you're boycotting the gunnels.
Well,
I love their coffee.
It's in fact it's the best coffee.
Right.
But they gone to drive through lanes.
Yeah.
And so what happened is,
I mean time did
the lanes the other day.
It took me 13 minutes to get my coffee to the Dreiser.
Yeah.
And yeah,
and because even though they have two lanes,
yeah,
they don't process it as fast as they should.
So the,
sure,
so from a customer point of view,
Margaret and I talked to them about that.
What do you
do,
Sam?
Becoming my dad.
He talks them,
here's the second step though.
Jeans.
Yeah.
You're not,
you're voicing your opinion on this show.
Right.
You need to be talking to corporate headquarters right now because that's,
that's a few years from now.
I can't,
I can't go full dad yet.
That's another level.
Right now it's like I just keep it internal.
I'm not trying to get someone in trouble.
You know what I mean?
Trying to get someone fired.
I'm not trying to be like,
I'm just venting to you and hundreds of thousands of other people.
Sure.
Who listen.
But yeah,
I'm not going to go pull the manager aside.
Well that's a full fucking dad moved.
That's when you're really angry at the world.
It's like,
this is like a level five irritation,
venting irritation.
That's somewhere to put your complaints in the world somewhere to be angry.
Yeah.
But then we have a customer service [inaudible] I don't know.
Let me think.
I was Starbucks.
I am disappointing because as a former employee of theirs,
I believe that they should have high standards.
They're a great company and they do work really hard.
Yeah.
Um,
I'm sure there's tons of stuff.
I feel the same.
I get irritated if,
I mean they get the blacks out of there quickly,
like they do things,
you know,
that they closed down for sensitivity training a while back.
I went that day.
Yeah,
I was,
I walked in,
I tried to walk into those stupid,
I'm like,
hello.
I met like we are raised this where the training right now.
I was like,
oh sorry.
Uh,
they wouldn't let me in because I went there just at the,
as they were closing,
they were like,
no whites allowed
you to experience it now,
Bro.
Um,
I get,
I get annoyed too with long lines at coffee places because efficiency is key.
Definitely.
And if you're waiting and waiting and you're like,
dude,
if I can kill me,
kill me.
I don't like that.
I get more annoyed with airports,
slowness and airline inefficiency.
I get annoyed where it's like a late night or a late flight.
You're on the last flight of the day and you're waiting and you're waiting and
you're waiting.
And then they go,
oh,
the flight's canceled because the crew they timed out or something stupid and
you're like,
wait a minute.
What does this have to do with me?
Like that's your poor planning.
FAA rules can only work 10 hours in a row.
And you guys hadn't thought of this sooner because they're supposed to be here,
but then they're not here.
Right?
I've been there many times and you're displacing so many people by doing that.
Like,
oh great,
now I'm spending the night in fucking Detroit because you guys can't fax.
You're steps ahead.
I have spent the night in Detroit for that and one of the best things about that
one horrible.
We got.
So we got delayed at the,
you're at the gate and they're like,
well,
you're not going to take off.
Everybody's like,
Oh fuck no.
And people get,
you know,
and they're like crazy.
Just get on the shuttle and go to a hotel.
And they were like,
um,
and you have to pay for it.
Oh my God.
Everybody got so angry that I watched.
I just couldn't believe that this is all it took in the United States.
You know,
at a major airport.
Everyone was like bull shit.
And they're like,
all right,
we'll pay for it.
Like they switched at the,
at the counter.
Yeah.
Well they should pay for it because you bought a ticket for a specific service
at a specific time.
No.
And now you're displacing people with small children,
guys like you.
You mean want to get back to your family?
You don't want to spend the fucking near Detroit.
I domestic.
I don't know why.
I mean,
I know a part of it is just like the incredible volume,
but domestically,
you know,
the u s airline industry is a fucking shit.
And you know,
when you go anywhere and it's so much better,
I will tell you Canada and Middle East,
believe it or not,
of course better in South America.
Yes.
Way Better in Asia.
Of course it's better everywhere in South Africa's fantastic docs here.
I know.
So you k great.
Yeah,
it sucks.
Dog Balls here and they have a monopoly and they can draw our shit from an
another cut and you're coming here,
get ready.
Know that it will suck.
It will send,
they don't care.
They don't fucking care.
They have you by the balls,
they have you hostage.
You know,
it's a bummer that Branson's airline didn't work out domestically.
Yeah.
I think he's folding.
Right.
But um,
I think he,
I don't,
I don't think sold it.
Oh,
okay.
I mean he did a great job though.
Alaska air or something.
Ah,
such it because virgin was my favorite one and I would always try it because he
brought a,
tried to bring a little bit of the international airline flavor dignity.
You mean treating the consumer like a,
like a customer,
like a valued,
but to see the whole thing.
I thought
it's,
it's that so many customers are animals,
you know?
I mean I'm around to of course,
so it like it,
you know,
people are absolute pigs in airports.
You see it all the time.
Sure.
There,
there are some of them treat the employees horrifically.
Of course employees then treat the customers horrifically.
It's just,
it's overcrowded.
It's um,
you know,
they make the planes too crowded.
It's too small because there,
there's somebody that measured and found out you can stick extra seats in and
you can sell those for this amount.
So it's like people are cramped there,
they're not getting treated well and there and it's a hustle,
hustle,
hustle.
Like land this plane,
flip it around.
Turnaround.
I don't know,
it's just,
it's a whole shit show of an industry.
It is a shit show.
Now on the positive side,
the cost of tickets has really not resin that much in the last,
it's really amazing when you interface,
you can fly across the country for what,
$450.
That's an incredible thing.
It is amazing.
Now they kept the prices low,
which is great.
In La,
you can fly to San Francisco for like $100 or $50 on southwest if you,
uh,
Vegas saying,
yeah.
I mean that's,
that's really insane.
That is insane.
That would take you,
you know,
five hours to one or probably three and a half,
four to the other to drive.
They're like,
pay $100.
It's,
it's ridiculous.
But that is pretty,
that is miraculous.
Yeah.
Um,
I never understand how they lose your bag so that,
that one always astounded me.
Like it's a direct flight from here to Atlanta.
How the fuck did I not,
my bag just didn't make it.
Yeah.
That did happen to me once,
but then it showed up like two weeks later.
The bank.
Yeah.
Anyways.
Um,
but that makes me crazy.
Oh,
you know what else makes me crazy?
The inefficiency of show business like a really crazy,
it really is the only gonna to make your brain melt if you've never been around
this thing.
The millions of dollars.
Yes.
Year.
That there's no,
um,
you know,
in most of most
you who have a regular job have some form of courtesy in your job,
meaning that,
you know,
somebody calls you and you go leaves you a message like a,
I dunno if we're going to,
you know,
I'd like to work out this deal where you guys sell us this and let's say you're
not,
most people go,
oh,
I'll call that person back and just tell them that we are not going
do the deal.
Right,
right.
Oh,
that's called courtesy common courtesy.
That shit
absolutely doesn't exist.
And it's one of the things is taking me the longest to get used to that.
If you don't want to do something with somebody,
you just ignore them.
You ignore them.
Well,
I'm talking about the actual monetary inefficiency of shoots and productions,
for instance,
are crazy.
Like your call time.
There'll be like,
Tom,
you got to get here at five o'clock.
I'm on in Santa Monica,
so you're sitting in rush hour traffic,
you're getting there,
and then you sit in the trailer for five hours because they don't need you until
11:00 PM.
But you gotta be there at five.
It's always like,
let's just get people here or,
but don't,
don't get me there.
Or The star who doesn't show up.
And you've got guys like the,
the unionized crew who's been there since five in the morning.
I worked on a television show.
I won't say who this is,
but you've got the union guys who are putting together the sets,
breaking shit down every night.
They're there before anybody.
They've not slept there.
They're there,
they're making everything perfect.
Lighting Camera.
And then the star doesn't show up because they decided they needed to sleep more
that day.
Yeah.
And everyone else waits for them and it's acceptable throwing money like out.
It's crazy.
Here's the other one that annoys me.
Doctors.
Doctors are the,
it's the only business where you can just make people wait for fucking hours.
Like how many?
One time we went to go get a scan when I was pregnant.
I mean,
we waited for two hours.
Almost just the doctor didn't.
Doctor's not there.
Oh No,
no.
You gotta be on time.
Yeah.
He gets to come in and do his thing with you whenever he feels like intellectual
arrogance is what it is.
No,
that they're special and they know that they have the skill that can make you
wait.
Yeah.
Because if you,
if you go like,
you know
hurts and I don't like how can this not hurt?
And they were like,
you got to come see me to make it not hurt.
And then you go there and you're like,
I'm here.
When you said to me,
and they're like,
well,
it's when I'm ready.
When you sit in the waiting room for yeah.
For half an hour to 45 minutes.
I know we should do to get back at doctors.
Just make them wait for everything else.
Like if you make an,
if you're a doctor and you make an appointment with anyone,
they should see a doctor and your name and be like,
oh,
I'll just make you wait.
You wait,
you wait in this room and then we'll make you wait in this other room.
Yeah.
Like you're like,
Hey,
uh,
I didn't want to upgrade my phone.
I'm doctor a and they're like,
oh yeah,
yeah.
Just uh,
just stand right there.
I'll get this damn there.
Yeah.
And then like 45 minutes later I'd be like,
yeah,
we're going to get to,
I just talked to her phone.
Um,
or you want to get your oil changed after Matthews?
Gosh,
yeah,
yeah.
There's no one here,
but I'm just wait there.
Just wait.
Like,
could you imagine if if you or I showed up late to our jobs of entertaining
hundreds of painful.
Yeah.
I think that's,
it's so disrespectful.
It makes me crazy.
Low roof.
Lauren Hill and then,
um,
guns and roses.
What's his name?
Axl Rose would show up hours.
Late hours.
You and a half crazy.
But could you imagine,
you and I should have an hour late for our standard.
Like you,
we'd be fired.
People was showing up pretty late for awhile.
That was the word on the street.
People would get pissed too.
Yeah.
He showed up super late for one of his,
not this last special,
but the one before that.
He showed up hours later.
Craziness.
People have invested in you.
They've gotten babysitters because there's people that want to support you.
It's like,
it's not like they're just waiting.
Let's go out tonight.
They're like,
you specifically,
I want to give you money to see you do this thing.
That's so funny.
I don't know.
It's nuts.
Um,
can we talk about our yeah.
Shifts in a fall.
What about
a cat eating kibble?
Yeah.
Find it not ready.
Um,
but I'd,
I would play the cat eating kibble to know,
imagine the sound.
This is a,
if you'd have it,
if you don't follow us on Instagram or Twitter,
which I'm sure a lot of people don't.
And they just listen or watch.
This is the big news.
Go ahead,
gene me,
I get to tell.
Sure.
We've,
I'm very excited.
We've been keeping it under our hats,
so to speak for a while.
But gene and I have sold a pilot to CBS and we're going to be writing a script
for a Sitcom with the fabulous Scott Martyr who,
uh,
worked on always sunny in Philadelphia and the mic mic.
Yeah.
And he is working with us now to develop a show based on your mom's house.
It's pretty exciting stuff.
Crazy.
Right?
A lot of people set congratulations.
We really appreciate it.
So exciting.
Some people let us know how it won't work.
Appreciate that too.
Um,
yeah,
it's um,
it's,
you know,
it's based on basically these gene and I and our relationship and how we,
how we obsess on the little things and um,
this show,
all of a sudden you're like,
look,
are we going to do a guy coming in four strokes?
Probably not on CBS,
but I don't think we would do that anywhere.
Honestly.
This,
it's too crazy.
Well,
no.
So I mean it's just like what,
that's,
there's some things,
some jokes that you play that play well for this medium.
Like worse.
The joke and the execution of it works on a podcast and then some of them you
go,
oh,
that can translate to television.
And some of them don't.
It's not that coming for strokes definitely can translate.
It's like you go well playing that guy's drops and stuff like it works well in
this medium,
but that doesn't mean we're not going to have fun and try to um,
you know,
go after the things that make us laugh.
Wearing jeans extra time.
Yeah,
no,
it's super exciting.
And I just want,
we want to clarify it too.
A lot of people think,
oh,
you guys gotta when's your TV show on CBS?
It's not that far yet.
It's just a pilot script.
So we're just writing it and then they have the option to make it into a pilot
to her,
that pilot to not hear that pilot.
Yeah.
So it's just a script deal for now.
Yeah,
exactly.
Very exciting.
It doesn't mean that the show is ordered,
which a lot of people,
I understand why he would think that,
but that's a little confusing.
The language sometimes if you're not familiar with it,
but it's a,
it's very exciting.
And we were pitching it and I was like,
oh,
I was days away from my due date and we were pitching.
It's all these networks.
And it was,
people were buying it in the room.
It was crazy.
It was great.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think there's a lot of stuff.
So have you,
this was like,
you know,
the only time it multiple networks were like,
why don't you do it here?
Yeah.
It was very exciting.
And I'm excited to be with CBS.
I love,
uh,
I love them.
I like a lot of the stuff that they're,
they're airing right now actually.
Yeah.
Um,
but it's,
it's a big deal.
It's kind of,
it's kind of a big deal.
It's kind of exciting
and I'm glad I didn't go into Labor during those meetings because it was,
it was imminent.
Yeah.
It was so crazy.
I literally could have gone into labor as we were doing those meetings.
I'm not a good idea.
Um,
yeah.
So it's,
it's really exciting news.
I think we're going to,
you know,
have,
have a fun time trying to get it done and trying it out,
trying it out,
trying to,
trying to try it out,
try it,
try it out.
And we'll,
um,
hopefully have success in it.
And,
um,
you know,
it's something we've never done multicam show,
but no,
but I like a live studio audience.
I do.
I just do.
I love it.
When I was thinking about that,
I've done the,
uh,
the run on the single camera stuff and it's fun to pursue and you know,
go after it.
But I don't know,
our natural element is definitely doing standup
comics tend to thrive is when there's a live studio audience and I don't know,
I liked that tradition of it and I'm excited.
I'm excited to bring some of the stuff from your mom's house to do.
I made sure.
Yeah.
I'm excited to find out how much stuff we can actually sneak in there.
I know.
I also want to find that.
Exactly.
I want the,
um,
those sneaky moments.
Try it out,
Tom,
try it out.
That's going to be fun.
What is this?
It's a new drink and I'm like,
try it out.
Okay.
That'll be interesting.
We're going to take stuff from this
show and make it into a show.
My Dad got a boat,
he's got a four stroke engine.
I'm pretty excited.
Little things like that where the works like,
yeah,
you can say it.
Hello.
It's always like just a wink at your mom's house audience.
Oh,
it's going to be good.
Yeah.
It'll be fun man.
We'll see.
No,
it's gonna be great.
So there it is and I'm no big day.
Big Day.
Big Gene News.
Yeah,
it is exciting.
Sure.
I never thought,
I never,
like I said,
I never had that experience either and I've pitched many things and you and I
walked into these big network meetings and we sold the show in the room.
Like literally after we gave the pitch,
they're like,
we want it.
We're like,
what?
Yeah,
you'd never happens.
It never happens.
Not In my whole career and all this time.
No one ever wants anything I'm doing except for now,
which is fantastic.
And we know what we have the fans of this show to thank for it.
Definitely that what you guys listening to us,
we're just a couple of dickheads talking about farts are we still are.
We still are,
but yeah,
but now now we can talk about farts on CBS.
Quick Reminder.
We are streaming new episodes of this show every Tuesday at 9:00 PM Pacific.
That's two hours before the youtube video drops and you can wash it with us.
Blue Band is,
um,
is in there.
I joined last week.
I'm at Dj Dad Mouth One.
Sometimes Christina jumps in and she is queen genes one.
That's right.
And we watch classic jeans on the weekends.
It's twitch.tv/your mom's house podcast.
Here's another Seagal.
we gotta ask Bart what he thinks that stands for.
You know,
first good Tang replaces that Dick.
There's so many versions.
Uh,
somebody wrote,
uh,
that gt RTD is fat girls twerking round that deck.
Yup.
That works.
Finna gargle that rancid tasting Dick.
Yeah,
that's a from William from gums to really tight dentures.
Chris.
Uh,
for genital time reach top drawer.
Fine guys that really throw Dick.
Yeah.
Face goes to rear to delight.
Oh,
I like that.
Those are all from Mike right there.
Thanks Mike.
Yeah,
so really interesting.
Oh,
I finally got the,
um,
the answer to,
uh,
let me see if this is here.
Oh yeah.
Uh,
you know that this guy,
right?
The infamous.
Yes,
I know.
Watch this several times.
Yeah,
it's burned into my brain.
These there.
Why is he not here?
Don't worry.
Mary is here.
Okay,
so
this won't be in the CBS.
We're not,
we're not writing this into our show.
Oh Shit,
I've never,
I've mentioned that like,
oh,
it'd be great to understand the hell he said.
Oh it's a really fully,
fully milk.
The moment.
Hi Tommy.
To really understand this man stuff right here.
It is.
So I've been watching some of your past episodes now is Tom really enjoys the
video of the garage worker getting backed into,
I'm a Canadian living in Taiwan with my wife that my wife could translate cause
he got spooked speaking broken Chinese.
She said that he just yells in pain and the last thing he says,
which is what this guy says,
what Tom wished,
he knew what he was saying is stuck in broken Chinese.
No Grammar.
Just stuck.
So he's saying that he's stuck.
She found a link.
This is,
I've mentioned this before.
She found a link to the news footage because it happened in Taiwan and it said
the worker didn't have any major injuries.
Just bruises.
Thank God [inaudible] Fan Mike.
So that's pretty cool.
I'm relieved to hear that that guy didn't have any major.
A lot of people had asked about that over the years and uh,
he didn't,
he didn't have any major injuries.
God.
Yeah.
Well,
does that make that,
but then then does that disappoint you?
Like,
or you bomb that he's not super,
no.
No.
Do you like it when they get hurt in real life or no,
I don't want them to be really hurt.
That is funny though,
that he's not crippled now.
Right.
Oh,
see you do like that he's crippled Tom.
The guy's in a wheelchair.
No,
no.
I,
I liked that.
He's not really heard.
Of course.
I don't want them to be really hurt,
but it's still a funny,
funny moment.
Yeah,
I'm stuck.
I'm going to pitch stuff like this for the show them.
Maybe the executives would like that.
Of course.
If they have a sense of humor.
Tom,
Tom laughs,
Taiwanese man by the way.
You were right.
I got a lot of messages like Christine is a real stick in the mud.
Of course.
That's how it was spelled.
My Casey Anthony Oj bit and they were like,
it's hilarious Christina.
No Fun scene as a square,
whatever.
Nerd alert doesn't like the fun things and like I need that broad of here.
I know guys.
I believe me.
Did I predict it?
Yeah,
you did.
You said it was going to sound ridiculous.
Did happen.
Um,
it says Jenny was a gutter slut.
Jenny,
yeah.
Yeah.
With Forrest.
She knew what she was doing.
She took advantage of forest inability.
Well,
let's back it up the people.
So when we're talking about,
so last week we discussed whether or not it's fair to date and ethical,
unethical to,
to date a very attractive mentally challenged person.
We brought up Slingblade and Forrest Gump as being not necessarily very
attractive,
but just,
you know,
please Tom Hanks.
I mean,
at the end of the days he's a leading man.
He's leading man the track.
Yeah,
it kind of messed up the Jenny Jenny.
First of all didn't,
didn't she had HIV?
Uh Oh I guess she didn't give it to this forest,
but we don't know anything here.
This is what the email says.
Right.
So we talked about them and read their selfish woman whether or not Jenny was
being a real CNX Tuesday.
Right.
So it said
fourth didn't have the ability to recognize the damage slot bag.
She only wanted to reproduce.
So she took advantage of a mentally challenged ma'am cause he was the only
person left that would touch her HIV invested box near he got,
Tony represents all the women who keep a nice guy on the back burner in their
prime.
They go out,
they built hundreds of hippies.
They shoot heroin,
they joined the Black Panthers.
They contemplate suicide.
They can track several STDs and then they realize their life is nothing.
They need to settle down before the age takes over and they die.
They come crawling back to the nice guy on the back burner,
back burner.
It was always adored.
The priests let version.
They are now damaged goods,
but the nice guy doesn't know about all the coke binges,
acid trips and gang bang.
She accumulated over the years.
All four cs is that young girl that protected him from being teased and showed
him his first pair of tits forest would have been better off becoming gay
pirates with Lieutenant Dan,
pillaging other boats for their shrimp and booty.
If you ask me,
that sounds much better than being a single parent living in bumble.
Fuck Alabama trudat raising this autistic child.
I didn't know that was a thing by yourself because you're dead.
Gypsy wife could stay away.
Confetti needles,
dirty needles,
and random cock.
Congrats on the CBS pilot,
Kyle.
Well,
that's a very nice email,
Kyle,
and and interesting observations on your part.
Well,
it is kind of a refreshing,
refreshing take on a movie that people really just did back flips for it,
but now you say it that way.
Jenny is kind of a selfish twat.
I mean,
yeah.
Forest fell in love with her when she was pure and sweet and then she went,
ran off and it became a slut burger and then decided last minute.
Yeah,
I need to,
I need to have a baby.
I'll just take advantage of this nice dunk dope.
Who's been waiting in the wings?
It's typical hot girl behavior.
Totally typical hot girl.
She took advantage of him and yeah,
and she knows,
she knows she's got them,
you know,
no questions.
We got to rename that.
Jenny's Jenny's a slut burger Forrest Gump with the hoe ass Hoe gutters let
Jenny.
Yeah,
now I'm mad for forest because I feel like he deserves better dude.
He's or he deserve way better than Jenny.
Yeah,
I agree.
If I ever meet Tom Hanks and would talk to them about it too,
I'm going to talk to Jenny about it.
Oh,
speaking of my movie star lifestyle,
I don't know if I mentioned it last time,
but the uh,
the mood that I'm in called instant family has been moved up three months on the
show.
So it was going to be a February release.
It's now November 16th which is very exciting.
We went to the screening.
It's a great movie,
and I'm not just saying this because you're my husband and I adore you,
and if I need to be infinitely talented,
you're amazing in this movie.
You are amazing.
You're so funny.
You're the funniest part of it,
but it's a really good movie.
The movie is solid.
I mean,
I cried.
I don't see what moves me to tears.
I have.
I made a big shits and big tests.
I have Teflon in my,
in my veins.
I cried like a baby during this.
It's a,
it's a beautiful movie and it's so funny.
It's got so much heart.
It's a great holiday movie.
I'm so excited for people to see this.
I can't wait.
It's so good.
And you're so good in it.
The one thing,
it's weird and you guys are going to notice that his beard is so dark.
They took the gray out of your beard.
So I was like,
when I saw you,
I was startled.
I'm like,
that's not my gene.
It's true.
It's pretty amazing.
And your character is so funny.
And they dress you like such a Chachi.
I love it.
It's so funny to see you being a fucking deg.
That Dick Character.
It's great.
Yeah,
that's,
that's your wheelhouse asshole.
But I'm very excited.
I'm very excited that it comes out in November and I think it's going to be,
I dunno,
I think it's going to be a big movie guys.
I got to meet Mark Walberg had the screening and he shook my hand.
Mark and I are part of the 4:00 AM club.
You know what that is?
I follow him on Instagram.
We get up every day and we work out.
Do not get up before I am.
Yes we do.
Mark and I work out.
I think we text each other workout and he goes,
me too.
And then we work out and we have a good time.
That guy is up legit.
FYM cause I see what time he posts up before then.
He just really nuts.
He works out a lot.
Oh,
you should have seen us during the movie every day.
Do you think,
um,
we should fitness shame him.
You're making too much fitness,
much fitness.
It would not affect them for sure.
He makes serious fitness,
but he looks amazing.
He does.
He's 47.
That's cray too.
He makes a fitness everyday like that.
Huh?
He's doing right now 47 days in a row.
Like because he's 47,
47 days in a row of getting up at three something to work on making fitness,
fitness.
I go to bed you think probably pretty early at seven.
I think he's in bed pretty early.
A guy takes care of themselves.
See how many hours is that?
You have to go to bed super early to get eight hours of 7:00 PM.
He probably his shit,
he probably is.
That guy is really dedicated to the fitness game.
He is.
Um,
yeah.
Fuck Jenny.
Nah,
Nah.
I think about her.
She's fairly selfish.
Twice ever meet Robin.
Write him and tell him the same thing.
Hey,
Jenny was up fucking selfish.
Gutter slut.
Really.
Now how's the farts is coming back and Jenny is starring in it without,
uh,
what's his dick,
Kevin because of his Kevin,
because of his whole thing.
Do you know the gay Kevin's movie?
Um,
but fucking Kevin,
but fucking Kevin came out this weekend.
He's in this movie called billionaire boys club,
which was,
which was a VOD before it hit theaters.
What's actually VOD?
That's industry slang for video on demand.
But I'm a movie star laying the movie.
He's not the star of the movie,
but he's definitely the most high profile person of the movie.
And it premiered this past weekend in 10 theaters and it made $287 what?
Yeah.
Are you fucking kidding me?
No,
I'm 100% serious as the exact amount.
And do you think it's because people don't like Kevin Spacey because of the
scandal?
The thing,
the two probably a big part of it.
I think you know what?
But that billionaire boys club,
that's a remake from the eighties it is.
And then like I said,
he's not the,
like the movie was made two and a half years ago,
so it was before the scandal and he's not the main person in the movie.
It's that they didn't take him out of the trailer because we watched the
trailer,
the kid take him out.
He's in the movie and they're not gonna.
They don't have the resources to reshoot the movie.
I'm saying that the main guy in the movie is actually the kid from a baby baby
driver movie that was,
um,
yeah,
so he's,
he's actually,
I think the star of the movie.
But anyway,
to movie just tanked though,
I think too.
It's not in the Zeitgeists and the eighties people wanted to see movies about
kids being wealthy and shit decks and now it's like,
it's kind of reminds you of have you just not,
it's not,
maybe it's the time.
It's nobody wants to get shit right now.
We've got this email,
Jane at said,
I've listened to every episode from day one,
way before fucking camp.
I'm in the middle of moving out,
listening with my headphones to mom's house podcast episodes three 33 through
three 40 laughing my ass off my,
but my fuckboy polyamorous neighbors came over with a beer and said they were
sorry.
At first I was confused,
but then they said,
we thought you were crying.
I guess that's what it sounds like when you listened to your mom's house alone
in your house with headphones on.
I have to get back to fucking camp later.
Mommies and manual.
Isn't that funny?
Man Camp was one of my favorite drops.
Oh yeah.
That's from a Tourette syndrome.
A documentary where this little girl that was just her who said that she gets
sent to this camp and she goes,
sometimes they go to tracks camp so that they're with other children who have
the same thing.
Sometimes I say words.
She swears like swear fucking camp.
Well,
she says another word.
What does she say,
Tom?
She says a word.
It starts with an N.
Yeah.
What nincompoop yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
she's like eight years old.
Cute too.
Which way you're like I said,
he swears he's swearing,
but she's hearing it somewhere.
She's hearing that like our kid doesn't know that word.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
We all say that stuff at home.
You know who probably does know that word though,
or gusts?
I'm sure knows that word.
Her guests.
Our guests coming up.
Oh,
Bert.
Yeah,
I'm sure part.
Yeah.
You think he says it all the time?
Probably.
Okay.
He's a fat racist.
Baton races should be as next hour.
We should introduce him like that.
He's fat.
He's racist.
I think he'd like that.
Oh,
you hate that.
Let's do it.
I'm fat and I'm racist.
I am surprised he doesn't have a TLC show,
you know,
and they,
it's all fat people like the fattest comedian alive.
Follow him right now
and he's like
Tito's.
Oh my God.
With the fucking drinking.
Why?
Why does everybody love Tito's?
What's the fucking,
what's the deal with a Tito's?
I know.
I think there's some extra process they go through.
I know it's made in the u s and I forget.
We'll ask him.
He's definitely not.
He knows.
Yeah,
we should.
It's like,
it's like when everyone was drinking.
Zima is in the nineties huh?
Hey,
here's a peak question.
Hey Jeans,
I'm in the middle of a level five brown at the moment and I came,
came across my mind.
That requires further investigation.
Why is it you can pee without shitting,
but you can't shoot the shit without peeing.
I've never shit interesting without the preliminary piece stream.
So it begs the question why?
Oh my God,
it's such a,
I would love to hear feedback from you.
Maybe the p stream is the redheaded stepchild.
Nobody talks about in the whole farts.
Push the shit out debate.
Is there a deeper meaning?
I need to know as always keep it high and tight.
Ps Tom,
it's for sure the water champ.
Wait,
is that,
is that a man thing to do you have to pee while sometimes.
I mean when we discussed this before to you pee you shit and then you've made
more p and you're like,
it's one of your favorite observations.
But did I make more p or just as I was shitting or did that Pete,
that was like the what's lingering be more good question.
But boys have the same problem,
right?
That you have to pee while you share.
Yeah.
Why is that?
Okay?
I have a theory.
I was okay.
Maybe the bowel muscle,
it's bigger than the,
the the P O my soul.
So when that muscle is relaxed,
it's adjacent to your bladder or I dunno,
I dunno.
Maybe everything relaxes down there.
That's good.
It's a good doctor drew question.
We'll ask him that dropped down
to hear this new one.
Dear Dr Drill,
do you wanna see this clip of a Burt swimming?
Yeah.
So when you're ready,
that's pretty cool.
I think you'll like it.
Okay.
Ready?
No,
I'm writing this down.
Know that's the part that you got to.
How come I compete?
Well,
I shit but not vice versa.
It's really interesting.
Yeah.
That is nasty.
That was a footage of a Bert look alike and he pooped in the ocean and he shot
Charlotte diarrhea.
So much came out.
So much diarrhea.
Yeah.
And he and only he knew the diarrhea came out.
I think he kind of picked up on it,
Babe.
No,
he didn't know because he doesn't look embarrassed.
He thinks he just farted,
I think.
You think he thinks he just farted.
I'm looking at it.
He's looking at his whole stream of shit.
Diarrhea.
Yeah.
Look.
And then he's got it.
He's like,
I got to swim through it.
So now he knows everywhere the Fisher.
Can I ask you a question about hemorrhoids?
Yeah.
Well,
I have them now and I'm like,
I'm trying to remember.
I think they went away just naturally after I've been Ellis my way.
I just want to put it out there.
I think this is a good Burt topic to,
Oh,
hold on.
You do.
It definitely has hemorrhoids and probably has for decades.
He's probably going to have so much insight in the hemorrhoids.
I mean,
he's a guy.
You look at it and you know hemorrhoid.
Should I talk about it with this guy?
Yes,
he's definitely,
absolutely.
Okay.
We'll save it for work done.
We're definitely gonna introduce him.
Fat and racist.
The fattest racist comedian alive.
This guy uses the n word all the time.
Oh my God.
Um,
remember this?
Yeah.
Shout out to Thomas and core row.
Yeah,
no,
sorry.
No,
Yo Bird is fat finger blurt.
That two went up.
Strawberries like a fucking fool.
What have a new crazy lokes distract.
You're kidding.
Yeah.
He made it just for this appearance.
I'm so excited.
I can't wait.
This is an old one here,
but I'm like,
oh shit.
I gotta go.
I gotta take care of my [inaudible].
All right,
so here's the deal,
man.
Here's the deal.
We're gonna take a quick pause and as a deal man,
we'll be back very soon with a huge drunk each fat,
lazy shiftless comedian who will racist wheel in here,
Republican House.
And uh,
now we're very excited about it.
So we'll be right back with,
um,
a burnt crystals.
Oh.
Oh my God.
All right.
We're back from the big pause with a,
he's drunk.
He's obscenely overweight.
He's intensely racist.
Hey guys,
it's so good to be here.
We were doing like,
they were like as good a good new river star.
These are safe births.
Oh,
what's that?
Turn the AC.
It's,
well,
he's bigger.
Larger people get hotter faster too.
I did Marin's podcast the other day and he's got a new house at Martin's house.
Oh,
good.
Good for him.
As I walked up to it and I was like,
this isn't his house,
not mark.
Marin does not live here.
I'm so glad he has a good house because last house was a pretty,
pretty shitty for how much money that guy probably makes.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
but,
and then we went in and do his podcast and he was like,
I'm like,
oh,
you got an AC in here.
He's like,
I gotta turn it off.
And immediately I started pouring soil.
Of course our sweat bad.
I gotta tell you,
I know there's,
so,
there's a bunch of stuff we're going to talk about.
I saw the special.
Okay.
Yeah.
I got an advanced screener of it was a celebrity.
Well,
here's the thing.
A movie star or television star.
Highly in demand actor.
Writer,
producer.
Yeah.
I just say I want to see something.
Boom.
It arrives and I watched it and it's fucking awesome.
He did.
He hit his head.
He had his ear buds and he was laughing and I was on the couch.
Thank you.
I'll watch the front.
The back is,
I appreciate the shout out on the special.
Thanks ladies.
I did.
I did watch it.
I watched the whole thing,
man.
Um,
can I say or no?
Do I might ruin?
No,
no,
you can go ahead.
Um,
well he a special thanks to,
to Teddy Tom.
But here's the thing,
man.
It's so funny.
I think it's going to,
all your dreams are going to come true,
um,
for,
for your standup or your career.
But like the coolest things for me watching it was like,
there's a lot of funny jokes and funny bits.
Um,
I feel like it perfectly represents you.
Like you are in the special who you are for real.
You know?
And that's a cool thing to see.
Like I was like,
this is 100%,
cause you know,
sometimes you could tape something,
shoot something and you're like,
oh fuck.
Like that's not really who I am.
You know,
like,
or that didn't come out right.
Yeah.
But this came out to be this is you
to thank you.
This might be the best.
I mean I got,
there's only,
I've never read reviews or anything and you want your friends to like it and so
thank you.
No,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna hit you hard here in a little bit.
It was a really fun,
I love the title.
I think it's such a great,
it says exactly what you do.
Is Secrets all so fucking right throwback.
It's funny to call it a throwback.
It's a throwback to when comedy specials that were funny.
Yeah.
It's like somebody out there without,
there's no pretentious vibe.
He's just like glamorous.
No,
it's just funny.
It's funny stories and funny jokes.
Funny Guy.
I feel like.
Thank you.
Because I feel like,
I feel like,
uh,
I sometimes I feel bummed out that I don't have like an angled that I'm
preaching about days.
Everyone's got something to preach about and I just,
it was for me,
it's just funny stories.
Don't get me wrong.
I didn't like it.
I'm saying other people might like it.
Yeah.
It's really great.
Proud of you.
I'm very happy for you.
Um,
I have,
uh,
here's the audio thing they put out.
Where is it
only on Netflix?
A startling performance.
One of the defining live shows most of our time,
watch the comedy show the changed what comedy can be.
The cultural impact of this special will be felt for generations to come
handled.
Gatsby's
streaming on Netflix.
Krajcir also has one out called secret time.
No,
you got to give it to Netflix marketing for that.
Oh,
I gotta get,
I gotta give a shout out to the,
uh,
the end of the,
the end of the special as Tom Segura.
Oh Wow.
Thanks man.
Yeah,
I think it's so funny.
I never,
I'd never take any jokes or anything for people.
I just don't,
and uh,
Mark Norman,
Shane Torres both gave me punch ups like,
cause they were there when I was running this special.
Yeah.
And you gave me the end is the best thing
cause I only got bits and pieces from what?
Like I said,
Tom was watching it and I didn't have a chance to sit down.
But I really love that you talk about Leanne.
I love that.
Talking about your girls.
Oh by the way,
have you seen that?
Nor were they got the taping.
Yeah,
they were there,
but they didn't see them at the taping.
They did not see that.
I mean,
especially now they,
they know what's going on for their babies.
Their friends all have fucking Netflix.
They're going to be like,
especially like your oldest is in high school district.
She's in high school or friends or Netflix on their phone.
They're going to be like,
oh,
your dad has something on Netflix.
Watch it.
You believed in Santa Claus last year
and they're going to be like,
Hey,
you need your dad said you're a fucking moron this you're dumber sister.
Yeah,
I talk shit so much shit about that.
I had to go the,
I had to say to Georgia and I go,
listen,
I talk about you guys on the special and I make jokes about,
you know,
I love you,
right?
And they're like,
yeah.
And I go,
okay.
When I was like,
what do you got?
What do you say about us?
I said,
well,
the first thing I say is my daughters are fucking idiots.
And they both started laughing and they were to or not idiots.
And I was like,
well you are.
And then I told them the stories that I told him the special and they're like,
okay,
I can see how that could make me look like an idiot.
But they're cool with it.
Yeah,
they're cool with it.
They're fine.
And Leanne totally is cool with it.
Oh yeah.
That's the least.
The lady whose name you give out your like,
you can Google him.
She's
obviously,
she bought a website,
grooves.com for this so she could make shirts to fuck with me.
That's hilarious dude.
Yeah,
I that's,
that's fun.
She's cool.
Bling grooves in a color con and uh,
and I say she is,
I'm being dead serious because is she,
is,
she really is.
If you look at her face,
she's the girl I fuck with their car.
If you look at their face,
you're like,
oh yeah,
she,
you can see how she'd be a con.
Um,
I just,
I put stickers on our car and so like we,
I used to do it all the time and uh,
I would put like a,
make America great again when the election was going and she couldn't get them
off as she would lose her shit.
But yeah,
really fun.
The whole bit about,
I mean,
it's great man.
It's a great special thanks man.
You,
yeah,
it's a,
it's good.
You're gonna,
you're gonna have a,
I think a,
a fun time with this one,
man.
Thanks man.
That's the best compliment I've gotten you in Forbes magazine,
Forbes magazine,
Northlake night is this thing about me Forbes and they were like Burt's special
can this comedian can transcend a his party boy image into adulthood and I was
like,
whoa wait,
you're not going to start touring with a shirt or you know,
come on.
Matching how upset people would get.
Now like if you go on this 2019 tour and people are like,
we also like we all because you'd think that that showtime thing got you
exposure.
It's like this.
This could be a whole other level and then you walk out and you're like,
Nah,
I'm going to do the shark thing now.
People will be like,
why?
Why are you going to do Conan shirtless?
You have to own,
I guess I'll take my shirt off
doing it Monday.
I got to go shirtless,
dude.
I guess I have to
shirtless sitting cause like my belly man.
Machine of real.
Yeah,
of course.
Speaking of your wife and kids,
we were talking about this,
right?
What were we talking about?
We said,
well let's not forget it.
Getting out of a 90 day Rehab facility.
Struggling to treat your oversized liver checkout boot crushers,
one hour special secret time only on Netflix.
Great.
That's great.
Good promos.
We,
where were we talking about before?
About how when we all kind of started hanging out together.
We lived in proximity to each other and at the time you just had Georgia.
Oh God no,
no.
You had to,
you had both kids when we met you.
But I was just like,
I knew him a little while before.
You knew.
I knew I,
I knew him before right before I was born.
Cause I remember baby aila coming to the green room at a club.
That's crazy.
I know.
And what was making 700 bucks a week?
That's clicking my workout.
That is so funny.
Like it scares me now.
Like I don't know what scares me now.
More.
Uh,
the fact that Tom's going to be 55 when his kids go to high school or the fact
that I was broke as fuck with children thinking,
oh this will work out.
I can't believe it.
Two littles.
And they were so cute.
We come over and they'd be,
you know,
naked time nick of time and they're watching their cartoons.
I know people would ask us like,
why did you smoke cigarettes and gained so much weight back in that time?
I'm like I think cause I didn't think it was going to work out or like not that
he didn't think.
He's like,
you're like this is a really hard used to smoke.
I didn't smoke that much.
No I didn't know he didn't smoke that smoke around sets or like have a pre or
post and like no.
The thing is you think it's going to like,
you hope it's gonna work out,
but your reality of the living situation you're in,
you know you're,
yeah,
this is real man.
I'm at this better workout.
I can't believe I did that.
Like now looking back I go,
that was a,
those really irresponsible,
so risky,
which is high risk,
high risk,
high reward.
Yeah.
And then now I go,
if I
could just get like two more years with this,
I'm done.
You got to do this for another 15 years.
Two more years.
They stayed two more years of good touring and I can just coast,
just coast to coast.
It's got living expenses.
I'll be hosting a game show.
I'm ready to sell out.
I'm so ready to sell out.
Yeah.
Brutal.
Is Hardy shift schedule is so dumb.
Yeah,
I know.
It's so dumb.
I don't know another way to do it.
Tell him why.
Let's tell him.
I mean,
I want,
here's the truth.
If I'm being honest,
I know it's dumb because I did it dumb.
So that's why I know.
So like I know I'm not gonna give away anything,
but I know what's coming up for him and like
you haven't,
you've only seen North America.
Do you know how,
do you know what that's going to?
It's a dude.
I know there's a part of your thing.
I know there's a part of your thing coming up,
dude,
where I was looking at the dates and it was like one city Thursday and other
city fried and other city Saturday and other cities Sunday.
Then I'm like,
you have Monday,
Tuesday off another city,
Thursday and other city,
Friday and other side east side of it.
And I just said,
he's Sunday,
two days off in another city.
And they're like,
dude,
I'm telling you,
it's so much different than doing Columbus this week.
Oh,
a Hartford next week.
It's been when I did that run with a bar,
got c for one weekend,
one weekend,
I was a fucking mess.
You're going to do it for you know me.
I have,
I have a tendency to allow myself treats when I haven't earned treats.
And so those mornings at the airport where I go,
I don't want to be here,
my brain goes,
well,
why don't you go get yourself a treat?
And then I'm like,
okay,
Double Tito's and soda.
Sure.
I would tell him why is why I have no fucking idea.
But isn't there something about the way it's made or something that's
handcrafted?
It's,
it's uh,
it's,
I dunno,
I have no fucking idea.
I drank so little,
I thought it was vodka.
Tequila.
He's got Tito's.
Why does he drink Tequila right now?
By the way,
I cannot help but go to my daughter's school and think about you every time I'm
there and think about what you were like when you were there.
A monster.
Those,
that they straighten my shit out though.
Without them,
I would've been a wild dog.
I'm serious.
I was this close to like running the streets and just being crazy.
One of the guides,
one of the dads was giving a speech
about,
uh,
like be about the dad's club then.
Yeah,
look,
there's a dance club.
And he's like,
you know,
I was there and it was,
it was so bordering on being inappropriate was cause he was like,
you know,
I'm here for the dad's club and I just want to let you guys know that,
I mean,
this used to be our dream.
Like they're all girls when you were kids,
but,
and everyone's like,
oh,
you know,
you don't have to feel creepy when you're coming around and like hanging around
as you know what I mean?
Like
go harder,
go harder.
Talking about the showers.
I did
this a Gig in Madison once where it was at the club,
but they're like,
it's just going to be girls and their dad's like a sorority girl bought out the
club and I did this speech.
I was like,
one is ever going to,
I was doing like a sag and no one's ever going to love you the way your father's
love you.
And all the dads were like nodding and I was like,
it's a love it.
You'll never understand.
So you probably wonder how you could ever reciprocate the love that your dad's
give you because it's unlike anything else.
And I go and the out,
really the only thing that would even come close would be if you were to take
your roommate's panties and put them in a bag and give them to your dad.
I just stayed on it.
I was like,
your dad jerks off and he wants to jerk off again.
He's not jerking off to get your fucking roommates panties,
maybe socks,
whatever they have.
It smells.
Oh send it to your dad.
And I just stayed on it and there's like Dad's laughing like really loud and
then just absolute head shakes.
Yeah,
that is.
But the staff was like,
that's the best moment
I couldn't,
I couldn't.
Um,
I can't watch porn.
That even has remotely young.
No,
because George is 14 so all her friends are like,
they're young ladies.
Yeah.
And I can't,
I'm like fuck that.
Like I have to watch old lady like broken.
Interesting.
And it'll probably the age will keep going up then you can respond to as your
daughter's age.
Yeah.
Oh I'm sure normal.
Although my father doesn't seem
why they just married a 34 year olds.
So gross by the way.
So the,
the school year daughter goes to,
they did have father daughter dances.
Yeah,
they do every year.
And you have to go on as a costume theme.
I remember one year and it's super creepy cause you're like,
wait,
it's couples then.
Oh well I already know my costume.
What do Dane Cook and his girlfriend.
Ah,
she's like,
what?
She's 18 years old.
So crazy.
I mean,
look,
if they're in love,
they're in love.
I'm not shitting on it.
I,
I just,
I can't imagine typing anything in common with the 18 year old.
I have a hard time talking to my daughters.
Oh my God.
I can't imagine.
Uh,
do you want to play some clips from the special
oh,
please.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
he's been waiting a lot.
Can you tell me as many excited to have you Bert?
He goes,
he goes,
we're going to have so much fun with you when you're here.
And I was like,
in my head,
I'm in the shower.
I'm like,
there's going to be a scale.
No.
So a secret time.
It comes out this Friday,
August 24th.
Yup.
On Netflix worldwide.
Worldwide.
Um,
here's a clip.
Are
All
dog named Dolos
you turned the crowds laughter down.
Oh,
I see.
Yeah.
That's cool.
I didn't even know you could do that.
Yes.
Sorry.
The fuck was he doing?
He's just,
he's a glutton and he does the guy these feeding.
Are you serious?
Yeah,
he really,
some glyburide be one line animal and you're laughing.
Hardest Shit.
I don't know what
he's the best.
Oh,
I'm laughing my ass.
You're laughing.
And the look on pushes face is so disturbed and it's,
I think it's about some guy hitting a girl,
but it's only a marriage.
I've never seen that.
There's,
yes,
there's
really cool answer.
I remember,
and I can't share it,
this story,
I can't share this story because it,
it's,
it's uh,
it is a secret,
but Tom told me a story one time and it was a,
about a past relationship you'd have with someone.
And he told me his story and what excited him and the story was so disturbing to
me that I went and to this day it's like,
it's like Leanne doesn't do ass play.
You can't fuck around with her asshole.
And so I'll never be able to change her mind about that.
And so,
but I remember Tom telling me that now
to this day,
I think about that.
I think about those of knew what the fuck you would,
I honestly don't know what you're talking about.
I wish I,
I wish I could share,
but I would hate to bring it up.
And then you go,
oh,
I really didn't want it was like two guys talking.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
One of those young road trips.
I don't know.
No,
I don't know the one about bought stuff.
I really don't know what it is.
I mean him not wanting to share,
it's not even that bad,
but it,
but I just don't want to share it.
It's just,
no,
it's about sex.
It's about sex.
Is it about farming?
No,
it was like,
okay,
imagine if someone was like,
um,
measure.
I can't even say it.
Like measure someone's like,
don't you love Fajitas?
And then you go,
oh,
I do love Fajitas.
It's like in your favorite part when you just put your tongue on the,
on the metal and it Burns your tongue,
you're like,
no,
I don't do that.
And then,
and then your buddies like that is my favorite part.
And you're like,
when I was in the car going,
I'm never done that.
And now I'm thinking,
how come I've never done that?
And the,
how come I'm not into that.
I've seen it,
but I never done it.
So.
Got You.
Okay.
That's the story.
Expose anybody.
Exhausting.
Good jokes.
The Casey Anthony,
Joe.
So,
okay.
I gotta go get some coffee.
Right?
So where's kit you?
Do they know where Casey?
Anthony.
Yeah,
she's fine.
She's not guilty.
She's fine.
She's chilling in Florida somewhere.
I'm sure Casey Anthony is a person that I found out.
You could get core form online.
You just buy chloroform online.
A joke.
You didn't get core form.
It just,
it just sent to your house.
Amazon,
Amazon.
You can get chloroform.
I'm never fucking room.
I have a joke about that and even know it's real crazy.
It was so funny.
Yeah,
definitely.
Okay,
real quick,
just a summary.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I'm mixed.
My weekends.
So much easier.
Then like when they're in trial,
they'll be like,
this guy,
Bert Kreischer was on a podcast.
You said it.
So all right.
Tomorrow say Leanne's like,
how are you doing?
You're like,
what's the fucking questions?
And you divorced her,
right?
Okay.
Yeah.
So you're free.
You're free and clear.
And then you go to do a Gig and Tampa and you meet this girl at a bar.
She's Brunette.
She's super cute.
Yeah.
Got a little attitude,
which I know you like.
Yep.
And she's um,
she's like,
you're like a high and she like pantomime like puts her hands around your neck.
She's like,
ah,
I was fucking around.
He shot
two shots and I'm like,
okay,
we'll talk about that.
Yeah.
So she's,
she's giving you shit,
she's Kinda checking you a little bit and you're like,
ah,
I just got divorced.
Yesterday's and
pretty good.
Yeah.
And she's like,
step,
step tab and she's a fucking round with you.
And then you guys leave together.
He'd be like,
I haven't been with another woman.
And so long story
and then you go back to your hotel with her start making out,
you're like,
oh,
this is so new to me.
I know.
I'm just so used to one person.
And then she was like,
Oh really?
Check this out.
She drops your pants and she just goes halt and just fully down your throat,
spits on your balls,
put your legs back and like to change my diet.
I started,
it is a lot like the secret.
So she's just like,
every time you're like,
wow,
she just got back to choke,
you know?
She's like,
hocking Louise on you.
You're like,
oh my God,
my wife didn't do this.
She's doing the reverse fucking terrible hand.
Oh my God.
And you're just right as your,
your eyes roll back,
you're about to finish.
And she goes,
hey,
and you're like,
here it goes.
And as you come,
she goes,
I killed my fucking dog.
What's the question?
Why is the punchlines,
wait,
so you think it a ruin your orgasm?
I have that from,
from not even joking around.
Leann started ruining my orgasms with that stuff.
No,
I was having the orgasm one time and she was Anthony.
Uh
Oh.
Do you really think he younger than killed her daughter?
Ooh.
Are going to do that to her next time?
Oh No,
no.
I was having sex with her.
I started to have an orgasm if she thought my eyes and she went,
oh,
look at him.
Fuck.
It went away.
And I went,
hey,
don't ever talk during my orgasms.
And she's like,
why is that bad?
I go,
yeah,
cause I can have an orgasm now.
Yeah.
And so then the next time we had sex,
he's on top and she was,
and we were going and she sees it happening in my face and she starts smiling
like biting her tongue,
like,
and I'm like,
don't fuck it.
Didn't have it for like a month.
I was,
I wasn't having a mortgage.
Well,
I don't want a picture of this anyways.
I'm trying to work on that at Casey.
Anthony.
Yeah,
I think there's something to it,
right?
Yeah.
No.
So let's say Leanne dies tomorrow.
Oh,
here we go.
I like this scenario.
All right,
let's start off with,
I get $2 million life insurance.
Hey,
she's worth of a lot.
That's good.
2 million.
1 million.
Anyways,
so yeah.
Hey,
she's dead.
Tom and I like talk about this all the time.
Who's a secretary?
A boat by boat first.
What was the second?
What was the question?
What's the second wife leg spouse.
Are you with?
I'm saying Tom's going to go for like the Dalmatian.
She thinks I'm going to get a real,
a real dumb dumb like 25 years old.
Yoga instructor never pushes back.
Never challenged him.
Total dope.
Just like,
oh yeah,
yeah.
Right.
Like a total down,
down one of your comedy skits tonight.
Catch it.
And then she goes so funny.
Yeah.
And she goes to all your shows and watches every single one of them.
Great job babies.
So good.
And you want to get like heckled.
She's like,
that was great.
Yeah you were.
He's so funny.
He could make,
he doesn't turn it off.
I love him.
This is what I mean.
I am laughing all day long.
Yeah.
That,
that girl
I'd probably go with.
I'd probably go with someone like that.
I definitely would like to do some stuff that I haven't been able to do like
talking about you live a single person's life.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
I met sexually.
I liked like,
oh yeah,
we're going rough and rowdy.
Like yeah,
I'm not going to like Liam are very meat potatoes.
We haven't really like switch things up like done anything crazy at a very long
time.
You mean like fuck swings or like,
I dunno,
just everything.
I mean group sex,
things like that.
No,
are just young.
I want young.
Yeah.
Oh go.
I would go probably,
I'd probably go like 30 years old.
I know that's not young,
but 30 for me is really young.
Yeah.
30 years old.
You're 46.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
no,
no.
I go 30 years old and I start,
I start having kids again too.
Oh really?
Yeah,
yeah,
Yup,
Yup.
I did.
I definitely go to more kids.
Like a lion.
You got up,
you get out of it almost makes me excited now.
Like,
yeah,
definitely.
We have more kids.
And would you tell your daughters now?
I'd be like,
I wouldn't a sorry,
but like,
they're babies.
I know,
but you gotta be,
first of all,
if they're not in college,
will be in boarding school lands on here.
I'm not living with them all going to either out of their minds
and,
okay.
But I see,
I see him kind of with a party girl,
like,
uh,
like a bleachy blonde party girl hero who w Arizona State.
Yeah,
graduate.
Right.
She's got to have a bad attitude though.
Yeah.
Oh,
she's got tattoos on her ankle.
Tats a dolphin somewhere.
Always disapproving of him,
you know,
like having fun with them but being like,
just kind of snap,
kind of shitting on a moment.
Yeah.
I definitely need that.
I often think if Leanne died,
no one,
like if she died before me,
everyone will be like,
everyone would be like,
you should have been,
you know,
everyone,
like at her funeral they'd be looking at me like the wrong one died.
I ask Leanne one time if,
how,
uh,
how upset she be.
Like if I died,
she goes,
I gotta be honest with you.
I think I might be a tablet that relieved.
And I went,
really?
And she goes,
I mean,
I worry about you a lot and I feel like,
I feel like I take care of you so much that if you died I'd be like,
finally I can focus on me.
Wow.
That seems really real.
Very real.
Kind of tell us where a therapist,
right?
Yeah.
She's,
yeah.
Yeah,
sure.
Her a damn.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I definitely would go be Deb did on her,
her therapy sessions.
She was like,
Oh,
first,
first I go through and fuck all her friends.
Yeah,
you would clean up.
I clean up all of friends.
She's like,
mom,
dad,
just go through a tear.
Those up once ruined everyone's marriage.
I remember one time I told him which of her friends,
I thought I could fuck,
this is a long time ago.
Yeah.
And she was,
this was like,
we're not even friends with those people.
And I was like,
I definitely could fuck her.
And Leanne's like,
no,
you cut in tonight.
Oh No,
I definitely,
I know who I can talk and I know I can't fuck.
Okay.
And then Leanne brought it up to them at dinner.
I was like,
God,
now I definitely can't her.
She was like,
I would never have sex with you.
And I was like,
I think you're wrong about that.
And her husband's there.
Yeah.
He's like,
she would tell me I'm about it was better looking than her husband at the time.
I still am by the way,
don't even married anymore.
Oh,
so,
oh,
so she,
you could,
I think I still could check this out.
Wow.
I'm trying to get fatter.
I want to be like my hero.
His name is Burt Christ.
Jesus Christ,
the American comedian.
He's so fucking fat.
So lock in.
So in the last eight months,
I'll put on
starting on a half because I want to be fat like him.
I don't know.
They just send it in.
That's fucking insane.
I do have the,
uh,
the actual promo here of the show.
Um,
who do I get to remarry?
I probably wouldn't get married.
Did you do it?
Yeah,
I bet I can.
I can.
You don't.
You'd move to Ohio and you start writing
books.
I don't know if Tom died.
You and the boys would move somewhere nice.
I think you'd leave La.
You'd move somewhere Nice Santa Barbara.
Yeah.
And then you,
and you probably would not get on stage again.
I think she would hook up with like gardener,
the gardener,
maybe that team of gardeners coast-wide wide,
like,
yeah.
He's like,
Hey,
I have no seen him.
And then she'd be like,
he died.
And they'd be like,
this is nice.
You did right.
The chicks and you're like,
yeah,
I'll still write the checks.
And they like me and uh,
I'll say that I wouldn't want to give you some out that
you saw in your mouth.
Okay.
But then you'd be like,
no,
but you leave the door open and they'd be like,
Bang on.
And all the gardeners would run a train on me.
Is that what you're saying you took to,
that you jumped,
you suggested that you use the language,
they would run a train on
Bam.
You don't think it would tell me like that what happened?
I think it's more likely for Leanne to be with another woman than to be with
another man really young.
When I first met her,
because she's kind of like,
I dunno,
I don't think she,
I don't see her.
I do not see her longing for another man.
Like that just is not in a book.
See if you like this.
Ready?
Hold on.
Let me get this set up here.
This is,
this looks like it's blue's clues.
Okay.
Hold on.
What the fuck
you made this?
Eh,
oh my God.
Pass out.
Oh my God.
Who
did that?
I commissioned it to be done.
You are not.
You did not swear to God.
Are you fucking serious?
That is amazing.
They even got my gold teeth in there.
Yeah.
They put my gold teeth in there.
They have this made up bald spot in the back of your head.
Yeah,
I know what that is.
Bizarre that they'd put that in there.
That's Tony Solano and Eric Friedman.
I want to say it.
Make sure I say it right.
Are you serious?
That is fucking amazing.
So excited about this by the way.
I've been watching.
Did you post that online yet?
No,
not yet.
Oh my God.
That's fucking amazing.
Yeah.
I'm
sure that influences all the stuff for you to come in.
He doesn't this for anybody,
just so you know.
Oh my God.
Come on.
I also did with you.
That's so excited to pick a musical.
There was so many good ones I picked.
I'm sorry.
I had to pick a musical bed.
Four.
Where's this one?
The class.
Are they proud of you?
I am proud of them.
Here's the a classic one.
The classical music one,
let's see.
It's the same thing,
but with,
couldn't figure out what music to put in it.
I like this one.
Yeah,
he did a great job.
This is awesome.
Well,
we'll post it everywhere.
I
bet
we're about to pass out.
That is fucking awesome.
If you're just listening,
we'll post it everywhere.
We'll put it on Instagram.
We'll put it on youtube.
I'll give it to you to post if you want.
Please.
Did you see,
did you see my billboard by any chance?
Is it the image that I haven't seen the billboard.
Just my belly.
So it's the,
it's the art.
The,
yeah,
that's great.
It's fun.
It's Netflix sent it to me and they were like,
I hope you like this.
We really like it.
We're not making fun of you.
We just think it's going to,
it's real really stand out.
And I didn't see the right one at first and I was like,
ah,
I don't like it.
It was something else.
And they're like,
all right,
we've drawn up alternatives.
But once again,
we'd,
we'd ask you to reconsider this.
And I know that they were thinking that they thought with all the fat shaming
stuff was like,
as soon as I saw it I went,
oh my God,
it's fucking awesome.
And then they were like,
oh,
thank God.
I like when you posted your like,
this is so us.
Cause it's his next to mine.
So it's like me and like jacket black.
You see it?
Yeah,
I think so.
Well let me,
let me see it.
Pull it,
pull it up here.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So wait,
the billboard is just your of your belly or you'll shirtless.
I,
I'm so excited.
And where is it?
Where's your billboard?
Melrose.
And there's one on Melrose and one on Coalinga.
That's the one I got the one on Melrose.
Yeah.
Dude.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
I'm super,
uh,
I'm,
I've never been,
I mean it's not my face,
but yeah.
Yeah.
Oh that's great.
That's great.
Yeah,
that's great.
Uh,
so proud he bird.
Oh,
thanks.
I love that.
Fucking that cartoon.
So that was good.
That's really great.
Um,
does,
uh,
your dad,
has your dad hit well,
he hasn't seen the screen.
No,
he won't.
He won't watch it.
You don't watch it.
You sure know?
You get,
your sisters are going to watch it.
My sisters are going to watch it.
My Dad won't watch it.
My Dad,
it might make my dad nervous.
Why would I,
you know,
it's funny,
I love,
I was gonna tell you this.
I love when you remember a story in real life with one of your friends or
somebody told and then you see it in a bit.
I remember at Banana Republic story like 10 years ago.
Yeah.
So like it's to see this story like that you,
I heard in a car,
you know what I mean?
Like on our,
on our way to a bit that he worked out like it wasn't even,
it was just like a story.
He was like,
Oh yeah,
it was,
you know,
my dad,
blah blah blah.
I told the story in the car and then you fast forward,
he's like,
oh,
that's on.
That's an a bit,
most of them.
Most of what I'm doing,
and I'm not even joking I think are things I would tell you when we were driving
out to a brayer and we just pull shit.
There's a bit that I had you laughing so hard at when we were driving a brave
one time and I thought this could be a joke and I cannot remember how to do it.
It was about growing up in a,
in a white trash neighborhood and it was something about,
there were these two brothers,
Darren and Darren or Darryl and Darren and I was in first grade and I walked up
and he was fingering a girl in his front yard and I was just standing there.
I know it was,
I was in,
I was in first grade and he was,
but he was older and he was fingering her and I was standing there trying to
talk to him.
I don't remember the story,
but you were laughing so hard and I was like,
I remember going,
I got to work this out.
And I was like,
don't work it out tonight.
Because then he'll know that you got it from this moment or he'll feel like you
were running bits on him working out later and they never worked it out.
It's a little bit of that bit,
Oh,
what a neat story.
Then it's already making me laugh.
You you bring it back or anything I liked the best part is that you're standing
there like
so like are we going to play smear the queer later?
And he was like,
I'm in the middle of something.
And then I was like,
okay.
He was on his front lawn fingering who's under a tree,
just fingering this girl and I was so oblivious.
I walked up and I was first grade and those are my speedo.
Swimming.
Yeah.
I was like,
so are we play in smooth Greer later and he was like,
excuse me.
I was like,
are we supposed to be the,
we're new
like you wouldn't out of control drunk.
That guy
want to see one
bird.
Gracious do special secret tide is on Netflix right now.
Right now.
Wait,
who did these Jake,
he's a voiceover artist.
Really?
Is it a professional real deal?
And he's a real,
I mean,
yeah.
No,
this wasn't free.
Not if it was so nervous getting rid of so much fun with you.
I was like,
Oh fuck donuts are going to be there.
I head up so much like what happened to our doughnut eating contest.
I remember when I called you and you're like,
I could definitely fucking smash like it was right before the marathon and by
the way,
okay,
so you did so far in the last year he did a marathon,
a half of your half marathon,
marathon.
He just did a mini the triathlon.
What's going on with you?
What's all this crisis?
Yeah,
I think so.
I think I actually 46 45 you're turning 46
in November.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I the,
the marathon was the biggest mistake of my life.
If I could go back,
I would never run that marathon.
Why?
Why would you call it the biggest mistake of your life?
Because I went from,
we were all over around two 25 at the time.
All of us.
We had kept off the weight for so long and then when I ran the marathon,
I couldn't walk for a week and I couldn't work out for like over a month and I
put on 15 pounds immediately.
He's Zeus Ho ran the marathon with me too.
And he was like,
dude,
I gained so much weight after that marathon.
Wow.
Because both of us,
I was,
my body was unusable.
So you're just like,
I'm,
I can't move.
I,
I cannot express to you how little I could walk after the marathon for o week.
I couldn't get out of bed and move and like still my scapula somethings.
I mean,
it's just,
it's just an unneeded pressure on your body.
But,
uh,
it didn't stop you from doing all these other wacky thing.
Well,
I got did the triathlon because men's health hit me up and was like,
man,
we're so inspired by all these things you're doing.
You're making the average guy these accessible for the average guy and what's
next?
And I was like,
I,
I've always wanted to do a triathlon.
I've always wanted,
man,
I try.
I was on was scariest fucking shit.
I would die so that people understand what you're talking about.
There's,
there's,
there are full,
there are half,
there are like sprint one sprint.
But just so people understand you swam 400 meters water meters,
which is I think everyone,
I remember telling him to rnr,
he's like [inaudible].
He's like,
oh,
so it's doable.
But I,
that's what I thought.
Very doable.
Until you actually get in the water and swim and you're like,
okay,
quarter of a mile is a long swim and it's,
it takes me,
it takes me in the pool,
it takes me eight minutes to do and I am gassed at the end of 400 meters.
He supposed to go straight from that to a 10 mile bike ride to a 10 mile bike
ride and then a three and then a three mile run.
And so I did the swim.
Dude,
here's the biggest problem with me is I am truly competitive.
Like there is this part of my brain where it's like,
where I was like getting out there,
I was like,
I'm not coming to last.
I'm not gonna allow myself to come in last.
And so I get off of the swim and I get out first hundred meters and like halfway
in I look out and I'm like number four and I'm like,
I'm fucking leaving this triathlon.
And I'm like,
Holy Shit.
And I'm looking,
I'm like pay checking and everyone's going in the total wrong fucking direction.
Like they're all swimming wide.
And I'm like,
I'm like,
I'm going to fucking,
I'm going to lead this.
And then I start going,
I know I can do this swim,
I'm going to fucking lead this triathlon.
I get to the buoy and I cut real tight on the buoy and I do this move.
I'd only seen on a online,
I'd never tried it before,
but it's like a swim where you like kind of flip over your body and swim and so
you take your thing and then you flip on your back.
And so it's a way to turn.
As soon as I did it,
this Chinese guy jumped on my stomach,
sunk me underwater and dove over me.
I sucked him water,
breathed in,
water came up,
and I go to take another breath and another guy grabs on my back and pushes over
me because they're just getting you out of the way.
They're fucking,
it's a race.
They're fucking racing and I'm in the way and they're climbing over me and
they're punching like,
and I start getting drowned.
I'm literally drowning.
I'm in like probably a hundred feet of water.
I'm a hundred yards out and I slept 300 yards to swim back in and I almost waved
over one of the guys on the surfboard,
like I think I'm dying.
And then I just got on my back and like start a breeding and were still all my
back.
People were climbing,
let me tried to swim out wide and that's,
and I,
and then that's why they were swimming wide because everyone was swimming out.
Why?
Because they were like,
I don't want to get beat up like a fucking idiot.
And so I had just got trampled by like 40 people just swimming over me by far.
Is this one of the hardest part?
Easily?
The hardest part actually no questions.
I like bike is the easiest bike is a cake,
not a cake walk,
but like,
like an idiot.
Once again,
I get on the bike and I got a,
I bought a really expensive like,
yeah,
of course.
Yeah,
of course you've got the best,
like the best,
the best.
The guy and I Martin the guy,
this is a big fan of all of ours and he goes,
he's like,
he's like a British guy and he's like,
you know,
we can,
uh,
if we can do like microcarbon or whatever and look,
take a pound off this.
And I go,
yeah,
let's shave as much weight off the bike because we can,
and they looked at me,
it was,
or you could ride the bike a little bit and lose like 10 pounds and I'll leave
and be lighter.
It's like,
oh yeah,
that's right.
But I get on the bike.
Tell me real quick,
where you the biggest guy there by far
Tom.
I get it.
Everybody was just like leaving.
It must have been super in shape.
And then,
yeah,
I get up there and I was like,
I'm here for register for the triathlon.
And they're like,
oh,
are you in are clydesdale division?
I went,
excuse me,
it's for fat people.
They call them Clydesdales.
I go,
no wait,
I could have been in the Clydesdales and they're like,
wait,
you're just running the regular triathlon?
I was like,
yeah.
And they're like,
oh,
you should have registered for the Clydesdales.
And I was like,
no.
And so I was by far the fattest person there.
There's without a doubt in my fucking swimsuit did not fit right.
I love it.
It's like all these other dudes,
they don't even make double XL triathlon suits because no one does it.
It mean they do.
You have to get them a special ordered though.
Fucking hilarious fit people.
This is this is it starting right here?
Yeah.
Fuck.
Are you trained for this?
Thank you.
Yeah,
I train hard.
I thought you did.
And I was like,
he's gonna die.
And so I keep swimming right.
And when I get,
by the time I get to settle,
do we see all these people going wide?
Yeah.
I'm like,
where the fuck are they going?
Oh my God.
Hmm.
The bike.
I get on the bike and I start blowing past people.
Yeah.
Blow impasse really good in that suit.
Oh yeah.
I was like,
Hey Leanne,
you could have taken one picture where I don't look fat as fuck cause she was
like,
I was really hard to kind of get one of those.
I got on the bike and start blowing past everybody and then we get to this
uphill and the uphills by this prison and everyone I passed just fucking flies
past me.
Then we get to this downhill at the top of the prison and I started going on my
watch.
It tells you how fast you're going.
I'm going like fucking 35 miles per hour.
I'm hauling ass with my bike.
Full lying pass.
People going.
Why are they going so slow?
There's a cop going,
sharp turn,
sharp turn.
I'm like skid around the door.
I mean I really was unprepared for this fucking thing.
How hard is it to run after all that?
The running the first mile is almost,
you feel like your body,
you remember when
we'd go to Barry's bootcamp and you get off and you do chest and then you get on
the thing,
they're like,
my body's not working.
Yeah.
It was like that.
Cause you did swim bike,
you just swim,
bike,
and then you what you were kind of re recuperate after on the second mile,
on the second mile,
you start feeling good and then at the end of the second mile you're like,
oh,
I'm almost done.
I'm almost done with the whole fucking day.
And then I,
and yeah,
but then I got to this and it's Holly Shit out there and we ran through all
these Mexican families grilling out.
We ran through a park that's always Mexican families are like staring at us like
all these white people jogging and ridiculous outfits.
And what did you eat after completing this?
I didn't eat poorly.
I went home.
Yeah,
I ate good because I learned my eye.
I got a nutritionist from the mayor.
From men's health.
Yeah,
this girl's Cynthia.
She's awesome.
And she got me on a pretty strict diet.
I wasn't boozing.
I didn't,
I haven't drank for like a month almost.
I'd like this weekend though.
Yeah.
I'm not going to Columbus.
I'm not going to have a few fucking cocktails.
Yeah.
Columbus is a good cocktail.
Oh,
it's like the ass,
right?
Yeah.
This is a real clip from his special,
yeah.
Lower your expectations.
Really.
We're just getting drunk and telling secrets.
Secret top secret time.
Secret time when they get out of the shower.
I dry my asshole on the bed.
Bam.
We ain't got so pissed sometimes when I wipe my ass,
I spit on the toilet paper.
It's called Alabama wet wipe.
Beard looks darker than my wife has an orgasm.
She looks like Elvis.
Her country.
She loves Allen.
Yeah.
So you're pissed about that one.
No,
she got pissed about the wipe him drawing my bet on the ass.
Fold the bed.
Can you probably do.
I definitely do.
I get on the shower and I just go and I,
I put a little like pinch a little volcano out of the comforter.
I just sit on it and dry my asshole about his house.
I'm a nasty,
nasty,
really nasty.
Let me ask you this because I've got a few hemorrhoids from the second
pregnancy.
Oh,
Tom's like basketball,
right about this.
Cause he's probably an expert on Hamline had been down for Emma.
Throw up trying to be nasty.
He kept me nasty too.
But so tell me about how do I get rid of them?
Do I have to have surgery or is there a,
is there any other way to get rid of these things?
Oh,
I've had them come and go.
That's what I was talking about.
Why do they come and go?
What makes them coming up your way or your,
I don't know.
I had one in Singapore when I was doing the Australian tour.
I've got one in Singapore and I thought I had asked cancer.
It hurts so bad.
When does it hurt you when you're just sitting down or when your mom was
hurting?
All the time.
But they can come and then it's like,
so you pushed really hard to make a baby,
make a baby coming into in flames.
The veins down there and that's,
I had some during my pregnancy and I think it,
cause I was so hard.
He had a bad sister,
had a really bad kind of cluster of them.
She'll love to hear this part.
Yeah,
she will lose her shit.
But it only hurts wipe cut or no,
I think they just go away up the,
I think if you just,
you get to get a suppository.
What do you ever have?
You're never put his paws story I've done at once and it like,
I got it halfway in and then I immediately started shitting and I was like,
oh.
And I just,
I pooped it out right away.
I used to have a joke about,
but now only you have to,
it's very specific.
This is my impression of,
of Sabaas a Tori.
No,
no,
no.
I'll take it from here.
Wait,
I'm curious now,
what's the part that I liked in the sec story that you were like,
I don't know this.
Oh wait,
on the second story you told me.
No,
no,
no.
I don't want to know now
if we don't talk about it.
Okay,
here isn't another clip.
Sometimes my family gangs up on me like the other night we at dinner and Georgia
is like,
you're definitely a misogynist.
I'm like,
no,
not aliens.
Like how actually we were talking about it.
You are.
I go,
excuse me.
And then Georgia says,
we don't,
we don't like the way you talk to Alexa.
Are you?
Are you kidding me right now?
Excuse me.
Just think if it was a man,
you'd treat it with more respect.
I was like,
it's not a man or a woman.
It's a cylinder.
I bought an,
I'll throw in the fucking,
yeah.
Ooh.
And then one night I get into a fight with Alexa.
My fault.
I'm drunk,
right?
I'm really drunk and I'm calling her Siri for like two hours.
I'm like,
turn on the fucking pool lights.
And then I realize I'm like Alexa.
And the one in the bedroom turns on.
I'm like,
bitch,
shut up.
I'm not talking to you.
I cleaned the shit out here.
Here's a turn on the fucking pool and my wife comes in,
she's like,
who are you yelling at?
I was like,
no one,
isn't that right?
Alexa?
Alexis?
Like,
yeah,
I fell.
Yeah,
he's a good band.
Leanne.
It's my fault.
The pool lights are on bird.
I immediately,
the very next week I made that joke better.
Of course,
that's all it goes.
Fucking drove,
drove me nuts.
It always goes like,
where did you film Philly that,
uh,
that was the entire second show.
There's so many things that happened.
You get the relief of shooting in the next week.
Something in your brain goes,
don't worry about it.
Oh,
and then you say it different.
You're like mother,
and the joke is perfect now and he just fucking film it.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
so funny is I've got jokes now that I,
in my new hour that I am so much more proud of than in that hour and I wanted,
I want to do them now.
I want to get them out.
You know,
like I'm afraid that people are going to come up with these jokes before me.
like you ever get like antsy with material?
Of course.
It's a good thing.
Yeah,
it's a good thing.
But how soon until you take your next special tape it?
Yeah,
I would,
I would assume if I'm on the same pattern that I've been on probably next fall.
Yeah,
like a year from a year from now basically.
Yeah.
Don't you think?
I guess I was telling,
I was talking to Whitney Aranda,
Whitney Cummings on the plane the other day and I was like,
oh,
like if I had had,
I think if I had had three more months to work on material and that special,
I probably would have gotten completely board of it.
Like,
like there's a certain,
there's a sweet spot on when you're still passionate about the material that
isn't a hundred percent sure.
And then you phone it in when you go,
when you go on,
see you excited about it still here.
I was perfect.
The Zip lining story was like right at the port part.
Like I cannot tell that story now.
I can't tell but story,
there's two things that I dropped the day after I,
I taped because I was so sick of saying them.
Really?
Yeah.
I was like,
man.
So yeah,
it does get to a point sometimes where you're like,
I got it,
I got to drop this.
And there was stuff that I,
that I,
I was touring with that I shot,
that I cut from the special,
brought back to my new hour and made better.
I'm like,
now this is why I dropped it because I just made it better and now I like it.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
What's interesting is the,
the um,
the time travel story in there,
I had tried to slide in,
I tried to side it,
an iteration of that into my let my showtime special and it just wasn't working
the way I wanted it to.
And so I was like,
I'll leave it out.
And then like the,
and then I did the showtime special,
started going on the road right in new stuff.
And then that time travels especially bit turned into the best fucking bit.
And I was like,
oh,
thank God I didn't try to force a day.
Isn't that right?
Because I think that's kind of what happened to me.
And like this most recent one,
I,
I cut something around his leg,
I could leave it in.
And then I,
you know,
I showed it to a couple people and they were like,
it's not the strongest.
So I cut it and now I feel like one of them is the best bit in my current hour,
I think.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
I wish we could go.
I wish we could go on tour together.
I don't,
I'm tired of doing going by myself.
Well that ever happen.
We can do gigs together.
Probably not tours.
I know,
but like I want to go like I was looking at like,
it seems like Dave Chappelle,
all he does is go and see comics.
Like he's like,
he's at Michelle Wolf show.
He's the Amy show.
Is that Chris rock show or either that or they all talk together,
I guess he puts together shows where he invites people.
Oh,
is that what he does?
Yeah.
Okay.
So he's like,
do you want to come down to Atlanta?
And like they were just in Atlanta at the Tabernacle.
Yeah.
Which is a fun,
it was him.
Jon Stewart.
Chris Rock.
Yeah,
Michelle.
Yeah.
Couple of dudes with beards.
He also has pretty deep pockets from what I hear.
And I'm like,
I know that on that number he did that run at radio city last year.
Yeah Dude.
He was like,
I'm paying people strawberry money and like they'd be like,
you're not even like making money on this gig now.
He's like,
I don't give a shit.
Like,
like I make like 80 million a year bro.
I don't care.
Shut up.
He doesn't care how many,
what's the,
what's the perfect amount of shows to tape?
Cause he taped like nine in DC.
It's way too way too,
but if you figure,
if you did nine shows,
you'd definitely have an amazing special for,
I think as as like that's a Max.
Why would you want to take more than that?
Yeah,
I would for,
and it's like if I didn't get it in for
my,
when I did this one,
the first show I fucking sucked.
I was tape two shows take two.
Got It too.
And the first one sucked.
I think Joe said he taped for this last time.
Yeah,
it's good.
he did it.
He did it in the Wilbur?
Yes.
Yeah.
I think great fucking bang.
That is in Boston.
I'm going to do that one.
I think in 2019.
Nice.
We're all touring,
uh,
pretty,
pretty big in 2019 the three of us are,
we are me and you out at the same time.
You took a look at my schedule or we were not overlapping,
right?
No,
like some,
some of the stuff is going to be like different mark,
like same market,
like two months apart by the closest it gets.
I think that's not bad.
I almost set you how much I was making these gig on accident.
I can do that.
I know.
And then I was like,
I probably should.
Um,
now,
uh,
you do say the n word a lot and your new special.
Hey,
let's check out this clip right here.
Uh,
want to make sure,
wait,
can you hear it again?
Yeah.
Okay.
That'd be great if he became known as the n word.
I have a bit,
I have a bit with the n word in it.
That is the funniest bit I have right now.
I can't tell.
I can't tell it because it's not perfect.
It's not perfect.
And in order to make it a perfect bit,
I'd have to do it on stage and in order to make it perfect,
I would have to say the n word 150 times.
No,
I can't be that guy.
I can't please.
It's so fucking funny.
It's the funniest fucking bit teasing the audience.
Give it to us.
No high cause like I just,
it's such a good fucking story.
What's the big deal?
Come on.
No,
you're not going to tell us.
No.
If I,
if I figured out off,
I'll tell I can't use the m word has to be said in this story.
It has to be in the story and it's not even me saying it.
I understand that.
So go ahead.
But then I have to know in order to make it good,
I'd,
I'd have to say the word nonstop.
You're saying someone else says it.
Yeah.
Go for it.
Okay.
Here it is a good story.
Um,
all right.
So trigger warning,
if you get upset by words obviously.
Yeah,
stop listening.
So,
um,
so when I was,
I used to work safe escort for say fast scored at Florida state or I used to
walk girls' cross campus.
Yeah.
That's what I did for a job in college.
And uh,
how are you qualified to do that?
Oh my buddy Chris hired me and he's just like walk to go back.
Like is it like late night kind of stuff?
Um,
that wise.
Like is it evening?
You were probably drunk,
no,
sober.
I was still sober.
So one night,
it was a Saturday night,
I was working at my buddy Chris Carter,
who was my supervisor.
And he's like,
hey man,
if you got the keys to the car,
cause he had a car and accused of the office,
can you just drop them off at my house?
I have to be there tomorrow.
And I was like,
yeah.
And he's on me.
He's like,
I'm having a party so feel free to come in and have a drink.
And I was like,
all right.
So I smoke a little weed.
I get in my,
I was driving my sisters blue convertible Ford Mustang.
I put in some fish back then put my hair in a ponytail and I head over to Chris
Carter's,
right.
So I pull up and it's a massive fucking party.
I mean it's,
I've,
I went to school at Florida state and I knew a lot of people in college,
but I don't know one person that's a party.
I pull in this,
in this,
uh,
for this convertible and I can't even find a spot to park.
And I'm bumping into people like it with my car to get through the party and
people are getting pissed and I'm like,
fuck it.
I'll come back tomorrow.
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna deal with it.
So I pull out of the party,
it takes me forever to get out of the party and it's in one of those big
complexes and I pull around to the other side.
And on the other side is an equally big party,
except it's for Fam U.
It's all black,
right?
So I pull and I'm like,
shit,
this is nobody,
by the way,
this is 1994 93 for this is right around the time with the Rodney King,
Reginald Denny,
and,
and race relations in the south aren't awesome.
And by the way,
it's Tallahassee.
It's a segregated city.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
So I pull in and I'm thinking,
fuck,
I can't get back.
I can't turn around and get back out.
I'm going to have to go through this party and it's fucking ray.
It's equally as big and I'm bumping into people and I can see people like
fucking Jesus.
And I'm like,
I'm sorry,
like I get into the dead center of the Party and the car in front of me stops,
doors open and they disappear.
And now I'm sitting in there in a convertible,
listen to fish,
I'm hi,
I'm starting to,
I'm starting to get like panicking Huggett get high.
You start overthinking things and a black guy just start staring at me like,
and I could feel him staring at me.
And I'm like,
not even looking,
just looking straight ahead.
And he's like,
hey white boy,
you scared and I'll say anything.
I don't even reply to him.
And he goes,
white boy,
I'm talking to you,
look at me when I speak to you.
And I kind of look over.
And he goes,
Oh,
you are scared are too.
And I'm thinking I'm about to get knocked the fuck out.
And I'm like,
no,
I'm not scared at all.
And he leans on my car like right where the window is,
leans on it.
He goes,
well,
tell me if you scared now mother fucker.
And he leans into my car,
hits the brights,
hits the horn,
and as best white boy voice goes,
no that niggers,
and he disappeared into the crowd.
Everyone turns around and I'm like,
guy grabs me,
starts to pull me out of my car.
My car starts rolling forward and the dude shows up.
He goes,
I'm fucking around.
I said it.
And they were like,
Whoa,
what?
And they put me back in my car,
I'm shaking.
And the guy goes,
it looks like you could use a beer.
I put my car in park,
I leave it running,
I walk into the house,
the guy fucking
murder two beers.
I'm like,
oh.
And he's telling everyone at the party,
I think it'd be a great story for stays,
but in order to do it,
I have to say the n word,
you know,
you said you have to say it 150 times to get the bit perfect.
It doesn't,
no,
no.
I'd have to,
I'd have to do,
it's the bit doesn't have a great ending,
so it would need a better ending,
like the,
and it's just,
it was just the funniest thing that ever happened.
It's going to end up being like,
it's going to end up being like a,
almost like an interstitial set.
Like it's going to set up something else for you.
That's what it feels like.
It's one of those bits where you think it's the end bit,
but it's actually getting you somewhere,
you know?
I bet you're right.
Like you'll figure out another story and you're like,
Oh,
if I tell this story right before that story,
it's going to make the end story better.
It's going to be like an example of something.
I Dunno,
but I know what you mean.
Oh,
he's burnt and racist comics.
That's right.
We did mention these guys,
number one,
racist comic in America.
Move over.
Owen,
Benjamin.
Um,
oh,
so crazy.
Lokes sent,
oh,
that fucking guy he sent in a diss track about you.
Oh,
did he?
Oh Shit.
Oh,
here.
Let's,
uh,
let's give them a little sample of what he did.
Christina could GST can now spray it up though.
I do support Chrysler,
Chrysler Burke,
Reznor,
you know science right up the Mesh.
Locks are the things we can keep on pushing.
Keep on,
keep on doing it as well too.
You know saying straight up now cause he loves his counts real.
He just said that one too.
We're just setting you up.
Hold on now we're going to see what he said.
Eight Burke Christ a buys.
You should know the TL.
Paula.
Good Hope you understood as I keep it.
Two thoughts.
Shoot.
Can you,
you promise to donate $10,000 to a children's hospital?
He lied or phone and as to no,
no to keeping it so to soap.
Really no big deal.
It's pretty good.
So I love it and I loved it.
He's worried about my health clearly with an open sore on his mouth.
Crazy.
He's like,
you did it again,
man.
Jesus Christ.
He came out.
Oh my God.
Quick kitten.
He got to where he got into doing what he does.
You know saint really started to love,
love,
hate.
All right,
that's pretty good.
Oh my God.
What do you think you're going to clap back or what?
Oh,
probably.
And I'll with his eyebrows.
Where are they?
Crazy looks.
Thank you so much.
Job.
Crazy.
Lokes I ran into the guy that made his barbecue.
Do you remember that guy?
Yeah.
Read them toward the store.
That's right.
Who's?
That'll match barbecue.
Oh,
so good.
Wait a minute.
Uh,
what's his name?
Didn't he have the Burger place?
It's not the guy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You think the Burger place closed?
That's right.
And then he lives in Portland now or oh,
that's right.
He moved.
Moved.
Yeah,
I remember that.
I remember.
It's crazy when you know someone through the Internet and then you run into them
and they're like,
Oh hey,
I'm a no Susko Hannah.
And you're like,
oh,
I know you.
So weird.
Oh my God.
Um,
do you remember when these came out?
Like a couple of years ago?
Can we,
we brought all this stuff we were looking at.
What's the plate today?
When you were coming?
Yeah.
Thanks.
Oh,
it's like songs,
people energy.
You'll shoot motherfuckers.
That's one of the best ones.
Yeah.
The gaping guy.
I like the golf one,
the golf one eye shadow dance.
Oh yeah,
my finger.
My ass.
That was the boat.
Is that right?
But,
but,
but as far as so many birdies fast,
I've always said,
how come my f like,
I feel like we share fans,
but you guys got all the autistic ones.
We really do have very talented people who listen to the show.
It's bizarre.
I love when people come up and they're like,
uh,
at the end of the show and they s they won.
They want you to know that I love you on,
uh,
your mom's house.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
no.
Like I don't really listen to your podcasts that much.
And I was like,
oh cool.
Thanks.
Yeah.
But thanks a lot.
Let's say we are describing people at last ones.
Let's say the adjective means fat.
Uh,
let's try using that sentence.
Oh my God,
I remember this.
Let's say Bob's Chrysler,
oh,
pesos the lab and every lab together.
Badass Chrysler,
how basis exactly.
Cool.
Basis x,
obese,
obese.
But he goes and then you see his like his throw is like perfect.
He's like,
Eh,
it just burn is a huge fat guy.
Yeah.
Just some cage factor.
I love when the fee,
like there was this guy that was
like a said something about me being a fat fuck online the other day and I
looked at his profile and he's so fat and then his name's like fat Mike.
Yeah.
Cause they just want to be in on it.
I had the same thing on an Instagram things guy was like,
Tom,
you're a huge fat piece of shit.
And I was like,
who is this motherfucker?
And then I'd go to his page and he was at least 80 pounds bigger than me.
Yeah.
He's like,
dude,
my favorite joke on your last special,
I don't know,
I'm,
I don't know if it was during your last special where I w but is someone going,
you know,
I figured if Tom could do it,
I can do it.
Oh yeah.
And that's it.
The last thing
so much better.
I love when people say that.
I figured if you could do it,
I could do it.
I'm like,
can you do what I'm doing right now?
I don't fucking think so.
Alright.
What's your favorite thing?
What's your least favorite thing people say to you?
Like,
you know,
um,
like after they come up to you to show and they're like,
good job instead of just being like,
that was awesome.
Like they'd be like,
you're pretty good.
You're pretty good.
That one irritated.
We always talk about like a backhanded compliments you get from people.
Like they're like not bad or like
funny stuff.
Yeah.
I think it's kind of funny.
And you're like the fuck I don't like,
I can't,
I don't really listen 100%.
Yeah.
Like,
I mean,
like I just tap out a little bit.
That feels like you.
Yeah.
And only because the one thing I cannot stand,
and it happens so much to me is people slapping me on the back.
Oh,
physics when you're shirtless.
Yes.
And because so many people like Anne,
I spend the majority of the time when I do my meet and greets,
looking down the line for the guy that's going to slap me and it's always some
guy who rips his shirt off and he's like,
Bro,
and he just comes in wide.
I spent so much time in line or like looking down that line for that person
because I hate when people stop and prepare for it.
Do you do like no and I never can see it coming and then the guys who think it
will be,
they never do it.
It's some guy he didn't fucking see it.
It's always a real harm firm handshake.
They pull it in tight and smack you on the back bro.
It's like the bro Hug thing,
dude,
and I do all my meet and greets shortlist.
I had a guy in Spokane who came in,
he like shorts off.
I was like,
yeah,
of course.
And then I grab him.
I go,
wow,
you're really hot.
And he's like,
I got a pretty bad fever.
I was like,
Hey,
are you sick?
And he was like,
Eh,
I'm not going to miss this though.
I was like,
oh my God.
no,
I'm going to get sick.
Yeah.
I would say if I'm a burden,
they definitely have zero regard for his hell no,
no way they're worried about is hell dude.
I had the one thing I,
I love when girls take their shirt off.
Oh,
that happens all lot.
Braless too.
Or just,
I've had a few brawlers I had a few bro.
I've had,
I've had a lot more broad lists them broad and then,
uh,
girls always want to lick my nipples.
Oh God.
You're like,
that sounds the closest I'll ever get the cheating.
And then I remember I was telling you that you liked this will show,
incorporate it.
No,
she does.
Yeah,
she,
yeah,
I like a little boy.
Um,
she,
uh,
I had these lesbians,
these to you guys
and your sex.
I have these lesbians in DC.
This is right when me two was coming out.
Yeah.
And uh,
they came up in there like we haven't played with a dick in a long time.
And I was like,
oh,
and they all just to take pictures.
And then they all kept playing with my Dick,
like grabbing my dick.
And I was like,
I was like,
Hey,
well,
easy ladies.
And then,
but they just wouldn't say it was four of them and it got so aggressive that
people in line were uncomfortable with it.
But I was cool that
there was,
they were,
they,
they assaulted me hardest spot.
Yeah.
Did,
uh,
like that.
Let me give you a kiss.
I'll give it a kiss and they go back and forth.
No,
they just kept grabbing it at different like,
so when I get one to stop,
the other one will grab it.
And then they,
and it was like,
how often does this happen to you?
It's my life.
This is my life.
Go.
I've,
I get critiques of tough from Tom.
There'll always like,
in Columbus this weekend,
I'm like,
Tom wouldn't do a meet and greet with us.
And I was like,
yeah.
I was like,
yeah,
I know he's smart.
I'm the one that's sitting out here shaking.
I should,
I must have shaken 200 hands after every fucking show.
There was so afraid of disease,
of catching sick and then bringing it home to my two babies and everything.
Like,
oh,
I just,
I think I've been,
I've,
I've had a head cold for this whole fucking year course,
but it's an allergies.
I get it.
As soon as I come back to la,
my sinuses tighten up.
I mean,
I,
the people really are you really gonna get mad at me for me,
I've,
I mean,
people like you're not doing,
oh,
they don't get mad.
They don't get mad.
I don't think they really genuinely good.
No,
I know it's like,
but like for instance,
the Columbus is like,
there's two shows a night.
It's gonna make,
you said like the second show was starting as you're doing a meet and greet,
like,
I can't,
I don't have your energy dude.
Like I'm done.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
like I do the show and I'm like,
that's all.
I can barely muster a fucking hello to somebody and you're out.
I wish I could,
hey,
you know,
laughing and I just can't do it man.
I'm not like you on that.
I wish I was started doing it.
Now I can't stop doing it because I've already started doing it.
And so when I didn't do a meet and greet for the Wilbur show and people were
fucking irate.
Right.
Cause they know you as the meet and greet guy either like he hates people,
don't worry about it.
Yeah.
And Leanne was like,
there's people out there that they were like,
she's like,
I think you really should go out there.
And I was like,
I can't,
there's 1200 people out there,
I can't go out and we're doing a second show in time.
And then people are like,
well if I knew he wasn't going to a meet and greet,
I wouldn't even come.
And I was like,
wait,
what?
And like,
cause a lot of people make like posters or bring stuff for me to have.
And so you know,
and then everyone wants to tell me like their version of like,
oh me and my buddy was just like you and Tom.
Yeah,
we bought it.
We've lost balls and yeah,
he was drunk.
It is odd though that,
I mean comedians are really the only performers where it's expected that you
would go out and meet the audience.
Like you don't go see your favorite band and then expect them to stand outside
dodger stadium and handshake everybody.
You know what I mean?
Like you,
you're not going to go see Weezer wherever you like in and then be like,
Hey,
can I meet you guys?
And if I don't I'm going to be irate about it.
Like it's fun.
It's cars are or actors.
And you had asked a lot to
like in,
in tweets,
people will be like,
are you meeting people after the Welmont a theater show?
And I'm just like,
what do you think?
That's fucking 1800 people.
Yeah,
I did it when we did those theaters.
I would go out,
they were being,
they would be waiting in the,
in the alleys.
Yeah,
like behind,
yeah.
That's okay.
That's cool.
I've had the the uh,
when they're waiting by the car because then it's like,
it's pretty limited amount and of course you take time to do it,
but an organized theater meet and greet dude,
that is a multiple hour event.
Oh,
I stopped doing shots with fans because I only a good idea.
Yeah,
really good idea.
I mean it was getting aggressive and then now I just go,
I can't do shots and people,
people are like,
seriously.
And then inevitably they fucking monster down whatever shot they bought from me
for themselves.
And then I'm like,
you're going to be sick like,
but there's no fun in this.
Of course.
Do you drink in this special?
I didn't drink.
I think I get a bigger like pay off.
I think people think I am drunk all the time.
Like I don't drink on stage but I will bring a drink on stage with me.
But I don't really drink on stage because I'm talking the whole time and I only
really drink if I am going to drink,
I drink it at like the 55 minute mark on the second show.
Yeah,
I'll go.
I'll have you.
You're going to,
you're almost done.
Well,
you gotta tell them machine story in,
I'll pound it and I'll be like,
hey,
by the way,
is this the one?
Yeah.
Yes,
I know it already.
I love it.
Yeah.
This is my favorite song.
It probably ever submitted.
I just,
it's so God said [inaudible] all talent.
Who blippy plastic.
I remember I wrote the song,
there's so many great songs.
I would dance to this at a club.
That's how much I like this one.
Yeah,
that's my shadow.
My Gosh.
Stuff.
But
this is a good song.
It is a good song.
I'm telling him.
He's fine.
Ready?
Yeah.
I
shadowed
so silly.
It's good.
And see that's even,
that thing was a,
that's actually a tip of that.
Like it's a wink at us making bad like our own,
our songs,
our songs that we had in that sense.
That's right.
What was that one called?
That was,
I made one called,
um,
uh,
or like animal sound.
No,
mine was Animal Sam then mine was Kentucky.
I Dunno.
Something like that.
I never gotten any fucking feedback.
No one ever listened to my own lists in between my toes.
I kind of turned me on.
Um,
I never,
when I wrote that the ballot of big Tommy bonds.
Yeah,
no one ever fucking listen to that.
Really?
Yeah,
no,
I put it up online.
It was like 30,000 views.
Nothing.
That's a lot.
No,
not a lot.
I think you'd get more on your little Edward's story you shared.
Now I wrote the n word in my book.
Oh,
this is great.
Yeah.
And I was like,
and I got to the part where I was going to read it and I was like,
I was like,
I can't say that word.
Am I on,
on an audio book is going to like,
I don't want to go down in history that way.
Right.
So what'd you do?
I called up Omar Dorsey as a black friend of mine and our daughters are friends.
I was like,
Yo,
oh mark,
you help me read my book.
He was like,
yeah,
anything man,
cause he came over to the studio and I was like,
uh,
here you go.
Just say that word was like,
what word?
It was the n word.
He goes,
you just called me over to say the n word and I was like,
yeah,
can you do it?
He's like,
yeah,
sure.
And he did it and I said,
can you do it?
You're doing it like too much like a black guy.
You do it like a white guy.
He was like,
why don't you show me how it's supposed to be done?
My Bitch Nigga by your own damn fries.
No that guy ain't shit.
Fuck.
Got Nothing on me.
Right.
Nothing.
There were white folks and then they're ignorant motherfuckers like you.
Yeah.
What's that from?
That's where his audio book before he became president.
Oh for real.
So it's just like you're talking about,
you know what's crazy bitch Nigga the first night of crazy to have time breath.
Do you remember the first time you ever heard downward?
I remember,
I remember hearing it and yeah,
pretty much.
I have a memory of like 13 like that's pretty much that memory.
And then I remember being yelled at me 14 yeah we yelled at you.
Yeah.
So weird cause I was and I was shocked.
Well it was right after I moved to the state of Florida.
Um,
Florida is such a great place.
Yeah.
It's Kinda,
it's that,
that part is as you know,
because all through before then I lived in the Midwest.
Not to say that there's no racist people and I really never casually heard that
said anywhere Florida in Cincinnati.
I mean,
there's obvious people say it,
but I'm saying I didn't hear it as a little kid.
Uh,
Minneapolis in the schools.
I went to Milwaukee,
nothing Florida.
Like day one I played basketball and uh,
I was just school in this kid.
I mean,
you know,
I was,
I used to play basketball a lot,
so I was just better than him.
He was like,
you play like a fucking,
and I was like,
what?
And I was like,
He's like,
what?
It's a compliment.
I was like,
what?
And I,
I mean,
I was stunned.
That was,
I mean,
I was,
I was a freshman in high school.
I had not,
I had not heard it.
No,
my parents said since beginning of time.
But also my parents
are foreigners,
so they would,
they don't even know all the gravity,
so I would hear that word all the time.
You're like,
ah.
My parents never said it.
First time I ever heard it,
I was in first grade,
I was in that neighborhood and there was a bunch of black kids.
First grade.
First grade,
yeah,
first grade,
a bunch of black kids coming to our neighborhood to play us in football and they
have,
my football had a Duke junior and I knew it was mine because my,
the lake,
we used to play in the street and to the laces.
It all run out.
And my dad had released it with a shoe lace with a Tan shoelace and they had my
football,
we lost my football,
they have my football and the two redneck guys,
one guy,
there's finger,
the girl under the tree said,
you got to fight them for your football.
And,
but the kids were older and one of the brothers,
I forget their names,
Daryl and Darren,
I think it goes off item and they started fighting in Darlington,
his front yard and Darryl and Doris Dad came out and started chanting fight,
fight and we're in a white,
white don't,
when we all jump in and put his arm on me,
put him,
put his arm on me and said,
he's fighting for you.
You chant it.
I was in first grade.
I was like,
all right,
fuck,
it sounds like a fun ride.
And then I'll remember.
And then and then and then by heard it,
I never heard it when it wasn't a used a lot in high school.
I'd never heard it in high school,
but like it would be sad,
but we had a black friend,
but I would hear the word,
but it wasn't like,
it wasn't like used.
And then when I went to college it was used a lot in Fsu.
Oh Dude,
the flu,
the worst flu,
flu around a lot.
But race,
racial tensions were kind of fucked up back then.
But here's the crazy thing,
and I said this to,
I said this too,
maybe I said maybe I did this in a bit one time,
but used to be the m were refused in like phrasiology all the time in itself.
Like it was used as a verb,
almost like in conjunction with the verb.
Do you mean so like I'll just tell you the bit
he's so passionate about the etymology.
No,
no,
no.
You really love your n word.
Jesus Christ.
If you like,
how you like,
how you like how you send me predict my behavior and I fall right into it.
The new racist comic.
I'm like hugging you some,
I'll give you some fodder.
We actually set it up and you came through.
You know,
I deliver guys.
So interested.
Okay.
Reminiscence.
First time he heard the word.
Okay.
What?
Here's a clip from the special.
That's secret time is your time.
Um,
I should have called an n word time.
Huh?
Oh wait.
So tell me,
tell me the thing you were saying.
I was the,
uh,
when Leann worked at the apartment building,
I mean this is like,
I don't,
once again,
I'm just telling all the bits that I would never tell on stage,
but this is Florida for Ya.
Um,
when we,
Atlanta worked at the part of building the,
uh,
we had a black guy that used to be,
it was our maintenance man.
His name was Antonio and I knew him really well.
He's to come by and watch Monday night football at our place and one morning I'm
looking,
I'm getting taken the girls in the elevator and there's a note on the elevator
door and I'm reading it like by the buttons and as I'm reading it,
Antonio Walks in,
he sees I'm reading it and he goes,
oh.
So as you know,
like pointing to the note,
so as you know,
some kids in the neighborhood,
he's going to get an a little ding dong ditch.
And I was like,
what?
He's like some kids in the neighborhood.
I was like,
what the fuck is that?
And he's like,
Ding Dong ditch.
You never played know what ditching he was a kid.
I was like,
I don't think I did.
And he's like,
you go up and knock on my post door,
bail out mobile,
come out,
you see him funk come out,
you fall out laughing.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
we did that as kid.
He's like,
what did you call it?
I was like,
nothing.
Because when in the south it was called Edward Knockin.
Oh,
that's what it was called.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's in the south.
And I was like,
oh my God.
Like I'd never,
I never called it that,
but that's what I knew it was.
I never really did it.
I don't know what kind of a fucking lunatic knocks on the door runs away.
I remember this one of those things I have a memory of with you.
Yeah,
it was because I knew it as Ding Dong ditching.
I did.
I never heard of it.
Nine Dash Oh yeah.
We called Ding Dong ditch and,
and when he told me his,
his Florida version,
I was like,
Nah,
dude,
I didn't hear that as a kid.
And then either a racist,
by the way,
in the south,
that's not even,
I mean that's just,
that's like the,
the Eh,
the m word was involved in anything when I was in like the live in that
neighborhood.
That was what it was called.
Everything.
I mean it just was included in everything.
That's where it was like a joke around about political correctness.
I'm cool with the little bit of political correctness about changing,
you know,
if you just take,
cause I don't think there were people that didn't even know that that was
offensive,
you know?
I bet there's still people in the south,
the go out.
It's like,
what are we Brazil nuts.
Yeah.
You ever heard,
what are they,
what are they?
They,
I mean,
I'm just saying you could Google this online,
but it said they're called Edward Toes.
Oh yeah.
Then it's so funny.
One time we were at dinner with her
really as a,
we were encyclopedia knowledge.
It's easy.
Tell us more.
You know,
so funny as I was at dinner with someone and Leanna grew up in Georgia,
she knew this about this too,
but she must have,
she had like rural Georgia,
right?
Oh really?
Like 1200 people.
So she,
she was like,
I'm a,
when I met her,
I went down south.
People were using that word all the time,
still in like 2004 when I was dating.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
And so I said Leland were at dinner one time with a couple from Kansas and they
had never heard that the m word would be associated with in,
in a phrase all g.
Oh,
you said like,
like a verb or something.
Oh,
I get it now.
You mean like,
like the Ding Dong?
Yeah.
And so it will be replaced and tea and they'd never heard it.
And I was like,
are you being serious?
And then I was like,
to Leanna,
I was like,
wait,
we grew up in the south but we weren't racist.
But what?
We definitely heard it,
you never heard it?
And they're like,
no.
So I go online on this guy's computer,
we're at their house and I Google it and I go,
here you go.
And I pull up this website and it's got all of them.
It's got them all listed and I'm reading through them and to the,
to him and he's like,
that seems like a little bit of a stretch.
And I go,
yeah,
I've never,
I go some of these I've never heard.
And then I look and it's official website of the Blue Klux Klan in the light.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
It hooks up to your web history.
It's like something to neo Nazi website,
but a god.
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
Race was weird.
And Florida are you a black guy who loves the flood?
Good Watch boot crushers.
New Special secret time holding the undead plex.
No,
you can piss on him and beat him too.
I like the music.
They the bed Jay.
That's all Jay.
Really Nice.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't know.
I grew up growing up.
I always thought I was Cuban,
like always felt Cuban.
You thought you were Cuban?
Felt Cuban.
Like I remember going to Spain and being able to talk Spanish and then I just
tell people I was Cuban and they're like,
you're not fucking Cuban.
I was like,
Nah man.
You know when you're part of me can you just Puerto Rican?
Yeah.
Oh boy.
Why you still a clip your nails and then keep the clippings on a piece of scotch
tape?
He taped under the table.
I got to put it in different places now,
but yeah,
you still do that?
Yeah,
I remember that.
Crazy.
It's the old school.
It's also Nah nasty.
It is.
You are nasty.
I am.
I'm pretty gross.
And the kind of guy that your girls will think like this is like the cause girls
model there.
You know it's true.
They pursue usually after their dad.
It's going to be like a nastiest guy.
It's going to be a guy that comes out quite far in his hand be like Sup Bert.
Oh my daughter.
I shit under the toilet seat.
Ah,
how do you do that?
How does that happen?
Do you ever,
do you ever shit,
yeah,
I was saying this on stage the other day and I didn't realize that no one does
this.
Do you ever shit.
And then it splashes up and hits up under the toilet seat.
No,
I've seen it though.
After his dad visited over dies.
Oh my God.
Someone said this was you.
No,
I shouldn't the ocean though.
One time like this,
you know,
I took a shower,
I took a,
Oh,
we were at a Catalina and we were to a secluded beach and I thought it,
no one was there.
And I went out and I threw his shit in the ocean.
Yeah.
Nobody was watching and I shit.
And we used to do it all the time at Florida and I shouldn't the ocean.
And then I got out and I could see it floating around and all of a sudden a
group of people,
like 10 people that we don't know come down to the beach and my Turd is floating
in the water in the waves and they're in the water.
And I see my turd going towards them.
I'm like,
I'm like thinking,
oh my God,
this is,
there's no way of getting evidence.
They're going to know that.
That's my shit.
Like you can't go,
oh,
it's a fish.
Yeah.
Oh,
you are nasty.
Do you still not wear underwear under your jeans?
Dude?
How does that,
it's gonna really shake your,
love it dick and balls.
No,
you're,
you're dick gets numb to it.
I my Dick's or a farm?
Yeah.
You're like,
I would pick the smallest finger.
Yeah.
What about your boogers?
I remember you're,
you're,
I'm,
I am
a vigorous nose picker as well.
Leanne was saying that you are like,
you really aggressive with it too.
When you'd roll it and then leave it in the furniture or you'd rub it on staff
flicker,
flicker.
I,
you know what,
in my mind,
I could be totally wrong.
I imagine is probably a real good nose picker.
No,
no,
no.
I was,
no,
neither.
No,
they're both,
the girls were kind of tame.
I would thought,
I would have thought that Iowa had like a real strong game.
No,
no,
no.
She does it.
She's,
she's not as dirty as you'd think.
They both shit at the same time during the day.
They both should have four in the afternoon.
Oh,
it's just weird that they would,
they won't shit anywhere other than their house.
They don't like shitting anywhere else.
I love shooting in strange places.
It doesn't bother me either.
Maybe because we travel so much.
She kind of has love shooting and like a burger king.
You do?
Oh,
I love shitting in a strange place.
I do really embrace.
I love having to take your shit and take it and I like you.
Shit.
How many times a day have you been going lately?
Three.
You push when you shit
now.
Now it's just like I got to go.
Everything's like,
I got it.
It's not like disaster shifts.
I'm saying their normal shifts,
but I,
I,
I don't wait.
Like I'll just sit.
It's like,
it's telling me it's time to go and it's,
it's pretty quick.
Yeah.
How are you liking the washlet?
I saw you guys had that.
Oh my God,
I wish they would be a sponsor to the podcast has changed my life.
I don't have hemorrhoids anymore because of it,
because it just sprays her asshole.
I remember the first time I ever had those in Japan.
That was when I first ever used one of those ones in Japan.
I loved it.
I took a shit so bad in Japan.
This guy next to me threw up one time,
no public restroom,
and he threw up next to me.
I heard him throwing up.
It was so bad.
That's happened twice to me that one time it happened in Denver.
I took a shit and the guy next to me goes,
oh my God.
He was like,
Dear God,
is that you?
And he started gagging and I go,
it's pretty bad.
Right?
And he was like,
when I was like,
are you throwing up?
He's like,
I can't,
I gotta get Outta here.
Did I remember in high school we did a,
uh,
like a class trip,
overnight trip where you go and you spend the night in the woods somewhere.
And we were a junior in high school and it was the morning.
And I go and I,
you know,
when you feel the gurgles you're like,
this can be a nasty ones going be loud.
So I walk in,
I'm going towards the stall and I see cliff,
my,
one of my classmates and he's like,
what's up man?
I do that.
I'll go,
hey.
And um,
I sit down and I'm like,
I'm going to wait for him to get comfortable because I know how bad this is
going to be and I want them to be locked into it,
you know?
But my asshole's also like,
you got to shit bad.
So I just,
I hold as long as I can and he just,
I see him drop his pants and he's in the stall next door and then I release and
it just goes right.
Huge explosion.
And within a second I just hear him go fuck this and pull his pants up.
I think he had a turd hanging out of his ass.
Just pulls his pants up and leaves because,
and I just start laughing so hard because I know how bad it sounds and I know
how bad it smells.
He left the bathroom is still like one of my greatest high school memories.
Yes.
Nice.
I was just telling someone the worst I've ever,
shit my pants was um,
tennis camp.
I went to a,
I was playing this Indian kid and I had to shit really bad and I was like,
oh my God.
So I just threw the set,
like our last ran the men's locker room and as soon as I went to go get there,
it was already kind of coming out and I shit inside my pants,
inside my underwear,
on the tail of my shirt and in my thoughts.
And I,
and I sat in it.
I like I shit.
And I sat in it and I had to get rid of all my clothes.
I had to break into a man's locker and get clothes to wear because I didn't have
any,
they were all covered in shit
to what is wrong with you guys?
Like,
don't you know how,
how much are you shitting now?
No.
Don't you know when you have to shit,
why are you,
why are you waiting until you shitting on Sundays?
Because I travel so I forget to shit on Sundays and Mondays are bad.
Today was fucking aggressive.
You should do shit more than once a day.
No,
usually once it once,
just once a day.
If I do,
if I eat spicy food I'll shit at night and then I won't shift the next day.
What about like in a normal non spicy shit in the morning or no?
Yeah,
I shit in the morning I've drink a big glass water and I just shit.
But I,
I have my shit's come out like,
like fucking like shotguns,
like,
like it's almost comes out all at once just,
and I'm,
I get it to the point where it's like,
okay,
we're building,
we're building and then write physicals.
Yeah.
And everything's good with,
you know,
blood,
everything.
But my,
my,
my thyroid's a little fucked up.
I think your thyroid is,
yeah.
I think I have like an over actor or an inactive thyroid or inactive.
I'm guessing he said it's trashed.
Trashed.
Yeah.
But everything else with you is fine.
That's great.
When the crazy,
yeah.
Cause you don't like,
it's not that you look terrible or anything.
No,
I'm saying you don't,
but it's like knowing how you,
how you fucking drive.
It's like,
oh yeah.
It's Kinda crazy.
Yeah.
I uh,
I don't know.
I I,
I mean I,
yeah,
I don't know.
I think it was Mickey Mantle Gene.
That's Mackey manager.
Here's the clip.
This is how bad of a parent I am.
This is true.
I went to a parent teacher conference,
stayed out until four in the morning.
Conference starts at seven 30 in the morning.
I wake up my golf.
Fuck I,
I make a cup of coffee.
I grabbed two diet cokes,
go to the parent teacher conference killer coffee before the conference theme.
It starts sit down to the conference,
crack my diet coke,
take a sip and realize I have a corps light.
It's true.
That is a game time decision,
gentlemen.
The second I felt the beer touch my tongue.
Oh,
that's like a finger in your ass.
In an orgy.
What kind of man are you?
Do you pull away from it or do you push back into it?
Yeah.
I pushed back into it,
not kill that fucking chorus light,
reach into my pocket and prayed.
I don't know the core like who the fuck wants a diet coke?
Have you just had a chorus line?
That's a true story.
That's funny.
You drew it's 100% true and you drank it and I cracked it and I to take a sip.
Yeah.
I'm like,
come on.
No,
no,
no one knew.
They didn't know.
No one knew.
I as soon as the beer tasted,
the bureau went,
oh my God,
I have a fucking beer.
Like I didn't realize how had a beer.
I thought it was a good diet coke and I just had to murder it cause I couldn't
like take a sip and and put it on the counter.
I just had to kill it and then put it in my pocket.
By the way,
I want you,
I want to point out that when you shot this special,
I remember you calling me like Tommy,
you wouldn't believe how skinny I am right now
by the way.
I had to meet by the way,
that's skinny too.
Was Two 30 in that,
probably do 27.
That's hilarious.
I can't fucking,
no,
I got to lose weight now.
Yeah.
The we'll get down to two oh five dude,
that's going to be so addicted to,
if I just,
can we make a documentary about you gaining it back though,
if you hit two.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And like,
I want you to go crazy.
Yeah.
We're the fucking throw it all back on.
Just wait.
So wait,
when you shit in Japan,
you just smelled that.
You're like,
oh,
I mean,
you hear a guy in the next,
I thought he was talking to me.
Yeah.
It was fucking bad.
It was really bad.
Uh,
man,
I remember that.
Uh,
there was,
um,
there was a guy who came to his show once with this girl and he was like,
we were talking about farts and he's like,
she farted still so bad in the car.
Then I puked in the car,
play about his girl's heart.
I was like,
oh.
I hung my head out the window through,
Oh my God.
We,
uh,
we,
one time my mom,
me and my mom,
my me,
the both girls.
Leanne,
my mom and my dad are in San Francisco.
We're going across now is it the golden gate bridge that has two stories to it?
No,
it's the other one is it that we're going over that bridge and money bridge?
The Bay Bridge and my mom is,
we had been at an amusement park over shooting birth conqueror and my mom is
motion sick.
She goes,
oh my God,
I think I'm gonna throw up.
Love these PC sitting next.
She's sitting next to me.
I don't want to hear this.
And she takes the clear bag,
they put the pictures in and she grows up in a clear bag and I see it and I
start drinking,
got dry heaving.
I start going and I stick my head out the window and I'm throwing up.
I'm going to throw it right now after I go out the window,
Ma,
my,
everyone in the car is dry.
I got to go.
This has been a really good,
I got it.
Yeah.
Well,
we're going to throw up.
Oh,
wow.
oh,
she doesn't,
she can't deal with throw throwing stories at all.
No.
Oh,
I can't even think about throwing up.
I play them just to upset her sometimes.
For Real.
Yeah.
Isn't there one from last week?
I feel like there was.
Oh.
Oh my God.
That made me laugh.
Um,
where was it?
Yeah,
last week there was,
oh,
here it is.
Yeah.
I played this last week just to piss her off.
Oh my God.
I can't watch.
I'm going to throw up.
I'm going to throw it
for real now.
Is it really fuck with you?
Oh my God.
Y'All throw up.
Really?
Oh yeah.
Just even looking at it.
Oh my God.
I'm going to throw up.
Don't,
don't fucking throw up,
man.
Oh.
Oh my God.
God.
All right.
Um,
Bert,
I'm so proud of you.
I'm so happy for you.
Uh,
you have a great special,
you're going to have a million new phones and uh,
it's gets really great,
man.
Thank you,
You guys check it out.
It is a,
it's going to be on Netflix for eternity,
but starting this Friday,
it's called secret time.
Um,
and then just keep following Burt for tour dates.
Uh,
listen to the Burke cast.
Here's our closing song.
It's called lick the ass.
Lick the bowl.
Okay.
By Gi Joe V.
All right,
thanks.
Bye.
[inaudible] on the street.
Good.
Someone put a beat to that.
We never had that.
Never had,
we never had that.
We were going to a good one.
That bag on the guy.
He never had,
never had that.
We never had there
as like a ball
sick beat.